hey everyone this is ravi from simply
learn
welcome to this google ads full course
video for 2021.
in this full course we'll be covering
topics like what google ads is
the steps you'll need to create a google
ads account the google display network
google analytics setting up goals and
even tracking in google analytics and
how google tag manager works
for this video we have our experts rob
sanders taking us through all the topics
so without further ado let's start by
talking about google ads
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit that bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn
when you're setting up your brand and
you need to make sure it reaches the
right audience and
provide the best results there's really
only one
place to turn to it's one of the largest
online
advertising platforms really in the
world
and that's on google and so today we're
going to talk about
how to advertise on google so thank you
for joining my name is rob sanders i'm
with simply learn and
we're going to talk about all things
google when it comes to
advertising so thanks for joining and
let's get right to it and talk about
google ads
and its effect with advertising so
we're gonna start out with what are
google ads well
google ads used to be called google
adwords
and it's been around a good while
almost 20 years now so really google has
grown at a really
rapid pace it's become one of google's
main
sources of revenue uh you could say
probably in the 90 percentile
of its revenue comes from google ads
and when we say google ads we mean
people who
pay for advertising on google.com
so google ads really what it does is it
provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc
which stands for pay-per-click you a
also may hear
google ads or ppc referred to as
cost per click or cpc or
sponsored search really what it comes
down to it's a model
so when you advertise on google.com and
somebody clicks on your ad
basically you're paying google for the
click
okay so it's just really a business
model where
an advertiser pays google to have their
advertisement
on google.com but they only pay google
when they get the click
so that's really in a nutshell how it
works for advertisers
if i want to advertise my business i can
go to google ads and say google place my
ad
on google.com and then my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as
i pay google a fee so google ads is just
an
online advertising platform developed by
google
with which advertisers can pay to
display ads
they can offer up their services there's
video involved
there's obviously mobile is involved so
you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available
in google's ecosystem so for example if
i go to
google search even if i type in you know
what is google ads
here i could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads
as my search query so in search you got
a lot of different things going on here
you have organic results
you have videos that are being pulled
from youtube
you got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets
you got an organic listing but really at
the top this is what we're going to
focus on today
we're going to talk about sponsored
search so you can see here for this
particular keyword query that i
typed in what are google ads really two
sponsored search or pay-per-click ads
appeared
now if i happen to click on any one of
these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website
they're gonna pay google a specific cost
per click
so that's how it looks on google.com it
really depends
on your query and what ads show up but
the great thing about your google ads is
they make it
known for the user who's doing the
search query what the ad
is so here i can easily pick out
what's an ad a sponsored search or
pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add
next to the listing and so by displaying
that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching
know that hey this is an advertiser who
is advertising their product or service
on google.com okay so that's how you can
differentiate between
paid search and organic search organic
search here
or even down here doesn't have that
little ad box
next to the listing so you know if it
doesn't have the little ad box you know
it's a paid search ad
now why do we want to advertise on
google ads because
it increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great
place to advertise because you're
meeting the consumer halfway
meaning somebody's typing something in
and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so google ads
advertises your product or service to
the relevant audience to ensure the
users perform the action required of
them so
it's really a great way to get
quality audience to your website because
if somebody types in something and you
happen to offer what they're looking for
basically your ads gonna show up
somebody clicks on it you pay google for
the click
and you get quality traffic in return so
the other great benefit
to being on google ads is increases
brand awareness
so it's a great way to get your product
and brand out there google has a vast
network
uh also known as the display network but
even on google.com
the search network itself the search
engine itself
millions of people use it every day in
fact here in the united states
it's been said or studied that you know
people over the age of 18
use search at least once a day at least
once a day here in the united states so
you can
figure that's millions and millions of
people so it's a great way to get your
brand
in front of a large captive audience
okay so top of mind awareness
refers to a brand of product being the
first one that comes to a customer's
mind when thinking about a particular
industry or category so
it really does provide top of mind
awareness
another benefit to being on google ads
is retargeting
so when we say the word retargeting in
marketing that means
you know showing our ad to somebody
who's already been to our website
so we can use google's display network
or we can run remarketing lists for
search ads
right on google.com to ensure that we're
targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something
or downloading something or subscribing
to a newsletter or visiting a certain
page
okay so if somebody doesn't do what we
want them to do it's okay
maybe they're ready to commit to our
product or service
and that's why google offers up
retargeting so it allows
us to reach that audience a second time
so they're going to be familiar with
their product they're going to be
familiar their website because
they've been there and so we can offer
up a very
unique specific ad to that audience so
that's a really
good benefit to being on google ads so
some other benefits here
increased intelligence so you know we
can certainly
get data about who is coming to our
audience
so we can look at what device what you
know
browser etc so we can really gain some
information about
who's coming to the website we could
certainly measure
our performance so with google we're
paying cost per click
and so based on that model you know we
can certainly measure
what keywords what ads are generating
traffic to the website and how much
we're paying for that
okay and if that traffic turns out to be
a lead we can measure that
against that specific keyword or ad or
campaign
so we can certainly measure our
performance all the way down the
keyboard level
and can we measure up against how many
conversions
or what we're paying for those
conversions so google
ads is a very highly quantitative
approach to advertising because there's
lots of numbers involved
and you're constantly collecting
information about
your advertising on google.com and its
network
and another benefit really is high
flexibility so
google ads has a number of different
options so we can customize our ads
based on an audience based on a keyword
based on a specific website based on
retargeting
so we really have a lot of options not
to mention the number of options
in terms of the ad format text ads
dynamic responsive ads video ads display
ads so
google ads has very flexible options in
terms of advertising and we're going to
talk about some of those as we move
along here today
so another big benefit here and this is
what i always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider google
ads because as we
shown here in our example if i go back
to our example a couple minutes ago
you know if you want to bid on the
keyword what are google ads
why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business
maybe you're in the digital marketing
industry and you want to help folks
who need help and advertising on google
ads
but what if you want to be found for
that organically well if you're not
found for it organically
then you can bid on it so it definitely
is a good
option if you're not ranking for a
particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option i always say that
you know search is like a fruit bowl
okay you have
apples and oranges and that fruit ball
well the orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search
they're different approaches but they
share the same fruit bowl
the same real estate so you can really
really help yourself
by using google ads to complement what
you're doing
organically so if you're not ranked
organically for keyword you can
certainly use google ads
if you are ranked for specific keywords
and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use google ads to help you
leverage the amount of clicks you get
from that ad so it's okay
to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here
we could see wordstream.com has a paid
ad
and here we can see just two spots below
organically
they're showing up with an organic
listing so you could certainly
be in both positions to try and maximize
your clicks
so it's definitely a good strategy to
run with google ads on top of everything
we mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility google ads does offer up
a really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that
again search is really the only medium
in which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for
and when i say halfway meaning your ad
is going to appear for somebody who's
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that
that person needs there's no other
advertisement
platform or another channel out there in
terms of advertising that
reacts the same way whether that be tv
or radio or email marketing or
affiliate marketing search is unique in
that regard
so search engine results pages are the
pages that are displayed by search
engines in response to an ad so that's
serp
and so you could certainly you know be
listed in the serps or
also known as organic search but the
great thing is
google ads is there to help you get your
brand or product in front of that user
looking for
a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads
on google search we have text ads so
text ads are the only ad
format on google search and so here you
can see in this example
you have a headline so not only do you
have one headline
you have three headlines in one ad so
jbl headphones
one headline wide range of headphones
second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with
with this text format is that you can
have up to
two descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30
characters the descriptions are up to 90
characters
and so you can really write some
specific information
about your ad about your product about
your service okay and the ad
is also going to contain what we call ad
extensions
so here you can see shop by category
in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something
on your website and so the purpose of
the extension
is to help get the click so the reason
why you're running google ads
is to get the click you want to generate
the click you want to get that traffic
to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad
i'll help you get that click yes you're
going to pay google for the click but
that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search
because remember search is there to
respond to somebody's need or query
and so if you get the click on your ad
chances are
it's going to be a highly relevant
visitor to your website so
google offers up a lot of
opportunity for you to write a lot of
information
in your text ad on google for google.com
so google also has
other formats and so they also have
responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean google
can
serve up a specific image from your
website
based on what somebody's looking for
based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size
appearance and format depending on the
space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you
have a large website let's just say with
a lot of different products and
categories
like amazon well it's hard to write
static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so
why not let google do the heavy lifting
why not let google
serve up the images and ads based on
what somebody
looked at on your website and so that's
the whole idea behind responsive ads
is it allows google to you know show the
particular ad that's most relevant to
that user
so it's a really a great option when
you're advertising on google you have
image ads as well so image ads are as we
mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay
you can see just an image app but the
great thing about image ads is you have
a lot of different size
options so 468 by 60
250 by 250 160 by 600 all these are
pixel
sizes so you have a lot of different
size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad
let's just say in comparison to facebook
where you have a thumbnail okay and one
size
for a particular image ad on facebook
first says google you have multiple
multiple sizes that you can choose from
in terms of running image ads so image
ads are really a great
option if you're going to advertise on
google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement
so here you can see an example for uber
so that's another
option too if you have an app and you
really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so
google owns youtube so you can run
advertisements video advertisements on
youtube
so they could be standalone or they can
be inserted into other
streaming video content as say a
pre-roll meaning
people are going to look at your ad
before actually watching the actual
video they went to youtube for so you
have a lot of different
options with video advertisements on
youtube
so the other ad format you have on
google are shopping ads
and shopping ads are really a great way
to get your product in front of the
right user
so somebody's looking for shoes or
running shoes
it's an opportunity for you to run
shopping ads so you could put that
particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name
in front of that user and so with a cost
per click model
if a user clicks on your shopping ad
then chances are
they're probably going to convert
because they could see the product
they could see the price they could see
the product name they could see the
brand
and so it's an opportunity for you to
really drive high quality traffic to
your site
with the opportunity to convert somebody
at a very high rate
so shopping ads are really good because
it prevents
unwanted clicks if somebody clicks on
that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so
if i go to google search and i just type
in running shoes
so my search results are going to list
not only some paid ads but a lot of
different options on shopping ads
so here i could certainly scroll around
and see
all the different brand names i could
see the price point
if i hover over it i can actually see
you know some other information
about it like reviews return policy
so if i actually click on this ad
chances are
i'm going to buy it otherwise why would
i click on the ad as an end user
and so that's the great thing about
shopping ads it gives you the advertiser
an
opportunity to really get your products
in front of people
who are looking for your product or
service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad
they're probably going to go ahead and
follow through with the conversion so it
doesn't necessarily have to be running
shoes it could be anything
that you have to offer a user so
running shopping ads on google is a good
strategy
if you have products okay so you can
showcase these
these shopping ads on google search by
certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory
connecting in some reviews connecting in
some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really
very fairly easy to set up google
shopping ads
within google search and the great thing
about shopping ads is it also appears
under images
and also pairs under shopping so if i'm
on google
search you know i can go to shopping or
i can go to images and i'll see
those same image ads show up here at the
top and i
will certainly see those under shopping
as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products
on google search to those looking for
that particular product so it's really a
great option with google
you also have call ads so when we say
call ads really
call only ads are great for mobile so
when you run advertisements on google
if you have a phone number associated
with your business
you can certainly add that phone number
to the ad so if somebody's searching on
their mobile device
and your ad is displayed along with your
number
if they click on your number they're
actually going to call your business
and google can track that they can track
how many people
click on your number and even turn that
into a conversion for you
so if you have a phone number associated
with your business
it's wise to go ahead and set up you
know what we call a call extension
as part of the ad because if somebody
sees that ad with that phone number
on mobile it allows them to easily just
click on the number
and call your business and so google can
track calls as well so keep that in mind
if you have a phone number and you want
to associate that phone number with an
ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads
i showed you an example of google search
so we looked at text ads we looked at
shopping ads on google search network so
google search network really allows you
to advertise on google search so
with google search if i go back to
google search
and i go to all i typed in running shoes
okay here i can see
shopping ads here i can see a couple of
text ads
so you have the opportunity if you're
running only text ads
to show at the top and if you're not at
the top then
google will place you at the bottom so
really depends on the keyword that
somebody's
querying in google search so it really
depends on how many people are
advertising
and so what google does if i didn't have
any shopping ads here
google will list a maximum of four
text ads at the top and at the bottom
any other ads
that weren't shown at the top will get
placed at the bottom so ideally if
you're running
text ads on google you want to make sure
you're always
at the top and i would say between
positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly
measure that remember google had has
measured performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on google
with a text ad you want to make sure
you're always at the top
so let's have a look at the different
types of
search networks that google ads
is affiliated with so the first
is google search okay so let's focus on
google search
and so basically when we say google
search or search sites we really mean
google.com or all google search engines
for that matter
so if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions
of people use it on a daily basis and so
if you're advertising on google.com
your ads will appear basically below or
above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches
for something depending on the search
query
they're going to see results now
depending on the device
as well so they could be on mobile or on
desktop
they could see sponsored ads or paid ads
they could see local listings
and they could see organic search
results
so for example this is what an ad would
look like so let me show you what that
looks like on google search so
if we go for example to google.com
and type in the keyword classes on
digital marketing
we could see some search ads here these
ads appear
above some featured snippets and
the organic search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors
in showing up in the top position second
position third position
and so forth okay if i scroll all the
way to the bottom you may even see
ads down here depending on how many
people are actually
bidding on the keyword phrase classes on
digital marketing
so we could see simply learn here in the
second position
why because again i can see the logo add
here okay so i can see
simply learn using three headlines i can
see simply learn using
there are two description lines here and
i could see simply learn using
some other extensions with the ad now
all of this is geared towards getting
the click so when you're on google
search the whole idea is somebody's
looking for something
you're offering that up and so it
doesn't even matter if you're in the top
position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions
in order to get the click okay so that's
the whole idea behind
being on google search if you're on
google search
you have the opportunity to be at the
very top of the search result
or in the top three above local listings
and above organic results now if i
change my search query
and typed in coffee in san francisco
my search results are going to be
completely different i'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to
google my business not google ads okay
so this is completely different so don't
don't mix this up with running ads on
google search
so google my business is tied to local
listings or google maps
and again with desktop which is what i'm
showing you the search result on
you're going to see likely google local
listings above
organic results okay and if i go back to
my previous query
of classes on digital marketing i'm
going to be able to see
paid search results above local
and organic listings so in other words
if you're running ads ads are going to
trump any
other type of result on google search if
you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to
google.com google also has something
called google search partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign
in google ads you have the option to
choose google search as your network and
then as an
alternative or an additional option you
can
advertise on google search partners
sites
and so some of their search partners can
range
so basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google
that's allowing google to show
ads on their site so the sites can range
anywhere between youtube to amazon
to new york times let's take a look at
an example
it could even be another search engine
so if i go
to say ask.com and type in classes on
digital marketing it's a completely
different search engine but i can see
the same ad
for simply learn so i can see same i
could see a different headline here
actually
but i can see the description and i can
see some
site link extensions and so notice the
ad is still at the top
in this case it's in position one and i
can see
multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad
next to it and i could see those over
over organic listings so these are
google search partner listings so you
can opt
in to be on other partner sites that
google
or other sites that google has partnered
up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that
option is display network so display
network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network
you have more ad formats available to
you
including image and including video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the new yorktimes.com or webmd
or marriott.com you could certainly do
that okay you just need to tell google
hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages
of being on the display network so if
you don't want to advertise on google
search
okay google.com you can certainly go to
display
and on the display if you're running
display ads or
or even video ads you're going to grab
the attention of potential customers
because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people
early on in the buying cycle can have
a very positive effect so you're
basically
reaching out to a large number of people
on google's display network
and giving them an opportunity to see
who you are as a brand
and giving them an opportunity to see
what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to
get your product and service in front of
a lot of people
because the way the display network
works is
it's a millions of websites who want to
have
advertising on their site and so you can
really
pick and choose a specific site where
your audience is going to be
and get your ad in front of that
audience so you can really
retarget to potential customers so
retargeting as we said
earlier is really reaching out to people
who have already been to your website
and didn't perform a particular function
that you wanted them to perform
meaning somebody came to your website
from
paid search on google.com and they went
to page a
and then they left so you really wanted
them to go
to page b add a product to a shopping
cart
and check out and purchase that product
however if they didn't do that
you could certainly run ads knowing that
they've been to
page a and page b and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website
and so that's what retargeting really is
all about and you can retarget on
google's display network so
remarketing your product to people who
previously visited your
your website or even your app allows you
to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of analytics
so google's ads has all the information
you need so let's actually take a look
at some of these options in google ads
for the display network so if i actually
go to google ads and i actually
go to display campaigns i can see i have
a lot of different
options available to me so if i click on
keywords for example
okay i can choose keywords for my
display campaign so what google does if
you choose keywords
basically what they're doing is they're
going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you
if you're not sure what websites to be
on with the display
network you can certainly just add
keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they
deem relevant to the keywords you choose
so you can also choose demographics
so on the splake network you can say hey
google i only want to advertise to say
18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in
on the display network you can also
choose topics so if there's a specific
topic that you want your ad to be
associated with you can certainly do
that
so google has a number of different
topics at their disposal
so here if i just choose a particular ad
group
now i have specific topics that i can
choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals
and so under each one of these topics i
can get really specific
so if i go under science i can see
subcategories under the topic science i
can see chemistry and physics and
scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose
specific topics where i want my ads to
be shown as i mentioned already you can
pick and
choose specific placements okay so
if you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on
you can certainly let google know okay
you can also advertise on gmail you can
also advertise
on youtube so you can really pick and
choose
where you want your ads to be shown so
you have all these different
options available to you to me one of
the best options
for advertising on the display network
because when you tell
google you have a specific audience you
want to target
and that audience could be somebody who
went to a specific page
or somebody who went to your website and
didn't convert you can associate that
audience with the campaign
and when you associate that audience
with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful
with google because you have all these
different options available to you
so with google ads you can also
determine how well you're reaching your
goals
which websites you're running your ads
on which ads are bringing in clicks
and which site gives you maximum value
for the minimum cost so you can see all
that in google ads so when i
actually pick and choose how i want to
target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this
data that google's collected on my
advertising
so i can see for example by age
range based on my campaign how many
clicks
how many impressions impressions are how
many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and
are clicking on my ad how much i'm
paying per click
cpc is cost per click total cost
and conversions how many conversions am
i getting so i could see
all this data available to me in google
ads
so it's a very powerful platform for
measuring performance
okay let's talk about how you can create
a google ad okay so first thing you want
to do
is you want to set up your campaign and
you want to align and go with that
campaign
just like we talked with ads related to
facebook you always want to align a goal
with your campaign just like we talked
about there
we want to do the same thing here on
google so
we have a number of different options at
our disposal
so when you run a campaign why are you
running the campaign
so if you're in just to drive traffic
or you're trying to generate brand
awareness okay
great you can still set up that campaign
you're just going to choose the display
network
okay the display network allows you to
get your ad out there on millions of
websites so that people can actually see
what your brand
product or service is all about now if
you're into direct response meaning
you're in it for sales and leads
then you probably want to choose
potentially
google search partners as a network okay
not display but google search
and the partner sites okay on google
search so
by choosing google search as your
network
it's director response so somebody's
typing in a keyword query and you're
responding
so that's the whole idea behind google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway
we want to be able to offer up the
product or service they're looking for
so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose google search partners okay again
if you're into
you know driving brand awareness or
product and brand consideration then
maybe you should choose the display
network the bottom line is you need to
figure out
what the goal is of the campaign that's
the very most
important very first step and most
important step is to figure out
what the goal is of the campaign and
once you've decided that
then it's on to setting up the campaign
and in google
you're always going to have at least one
ad group and what makes up an ad group
keywords
and ads so ideally when you set up a
campaign
on google search network you're going to
choose keywords and those keywords
should be tightly knitted
or tightly themed or in other words be
all relevant to one another
in an ad group so that's what an ad
group is keywords that are relevant to
one another
okay in that ad group you're also gonna
have an ad so when you
choose your keywords you're gonna write
an ad for those keywords
so step three is after you set up the ad
group and choose your keywords you're
going to create an ad
so let's take a look at how that looks
in google ads
so if i go to google ads i can see i
already have
an account set up i have a couple
campaigns so let's just say i have this
campaign set up here
i'm just going to call it industrial
campaign okay and if i choose
industrial campaign okay i'm going to
then
be asked to set up an ad group now if i
set up an ad group
already in that ad group should be
keywords and ads okay so remember
when you set up an ad group you want to
choose your keywords first
painless keywords should be all related
to one another
so for example i could see an ad group
here called fig
concentrate well if i click on this ad
group and i look at the keywords they
should all be related to
fig concentrate so here we go we can see
a few key words in this ad group in fact
i have 10 of them
all related to fig concentrate so it's
very
very important from a quality score
perspective if you remember when we're
talking about quality score
quality score is based on landing page
experience expected click through and
the ad relevancy to the keyword
so if you can choose a ad group and have
all your keywords related to one another
like i do here with fig concentrate then
it's
easier to write an ad okay so here i
have 10 keywords
all related to fig concentrate so now if
i go to ads and extensions
in the google ads platform we can see
here
i already have a couple of ads going
okay so
ideally if i wanted to i can run
more than just two ads as a best
practice
as a best practice you want to have at
least two ads why
because these two ads are gonna be
served up against each other
and ideally the whole idea of running
more than
one ad is what google can do is start
serving up the ad
that is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so
here i'm going to go ahead and add one
more ad here okay so if i click on
that plus button i have a bunch of
options here i'm going to go ahead and
choose text ad
because i'm running this campaign on the
search
network and my goal is to get
sales not lead sales so i want sales i
want somebody to click on my ad go to my
website
and purchase some fake concentrate so
that's my goal
and so if i'm on the search network i
can only have text ads
so i'm going to choose text at and once
i choose text ad
then i have the option now to go through
and create a new ad okay so what google
actually does
is they populate the ad from previous
ads
and so this gives me an opportunity to
tweak one of the ads i already have in
place
so here you can see i have a final url
and that's the url that the traffic is
gonna go to when they click on your ad
okay so if somebody clicks on the ad
that's the page they're gonna go to
call that the final url now i have an
option to create
up to three headlines so here i can see
headline one up to 30 characters
i have my brand name headline two i have
something
related to the keyword i'm bidding on so
what am i talking about
fake concentrate okay again up to 30
characters
now that includes spaces so if you
happen to go over 30 characters
your ads not going to get approved so
here you can see 32 over 30.
i'm two characters over if i just get
rid of that
the ad is okay so you got to be careful
to stay within the boundaries of the
character limits including spaces
so here i got headline two is fig
concentrate
now i'm gonna write headline three this
is new so this is
recently implemented by google and i
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you
you use because the more information you
can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for fit
concentrate
and you provide them as with as much
information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise
we want to advertise so that people can
see our ad and click on our ad that's
the whole point isn't it to get people
to click
on our app because they're looking for
something that we're offering
in this example fit concentrate so here
i have headline three
i'm gonna go ahead and put something in
a headline three maybe a promotion let's
just say i'm offering up twenty percent
so i can say up to twenty percent off
through april and may now you see i'm
running into character count so i'm just
gonna
go ahead and keep it at april so up to
twenty percent off through april now i
can create another ad
and maybe change the headline to say up
to 20 off through may
so you want to take advantage of all
three headlines now notice when i added
the headline here i can see a preview of
it
on mobile and i could see a preview of
it on desktop
now underneath that i have what they
call the display path
so what google does is they take your
domain in this case valleyfig.com
and you can basically customize that
domain
with what they call a path so you have
path one path two
and the whole point of this is for you
to
customize it based on the keywords you
were bidding on
so i'm bidding on fake concentrate i'm
gonna put fake concentrate in here now
remember when somebody actually clicks
on my ad they're not going to go
to valleyfig.com concentrate
they're going to go to the url up here
under final url
so you want to make sure you put a path
in here ideally what i would do
is put in something related to the
keyword i'm bidding on in this case fig
concentrate
now i have an opportunity to add a new
description
a second description this is new and i
have up to 90 characters
so i can go ahead and add some content
so remember with description 2
i have up to 90 characters so i'm just
gonna go ahead and borrow some copy from
the website if i'm not actually sure
what to write
and so here you can see fit concentrate
is a natural product containing
no preservatives or additives so that's
my second description
so now i can go ahead and save and
create extensions
so i'm just going to go ahead and push
the button save and create extensions
and when i do that i'm going to be
prompted to
go ahead and create some ad extensions
and so ad extensions allow me to add
in links site links underneath the ad
just like you see here
so when you've added your site link
extensions and other extensions
you save it you'll be able to see your
new ad here
here we can see the ad we created okay
notice it's got the three headlines
now this it's got the two descriptions
and if i want to edit i can just click
edit add
and go ahead and edit it if i don't want
to edit it then
i don't have to i can always go back so
you can always
edit it ad after it's been created okay
if not
no big deal notice when you actually
create your ad
in some cases google's going to review
it to make sure it fits within google's
guidelines and policies uh but once it's
approved you'll see it under
you'll see approved under the status
column and that's pretty much
how you would go ahead and create a text
app okay so when it does get approved
it's going to be in the rotation with
the other two ads and so what google is
going to do is serve up each ad
equally and then eventually the ad that
is performing best
will get served up more and that way
you're putting
your best ad always in front of the user
who's looking for the product and
service you're offering so now let's
talk about the metrics
so associated with these keywords these
ads these ad groups and campaigns
so there are a lot of metrics in google
ads a lot of metrics
and we're not even going to cover most
of these metrics we're just going to
cover
would i deem the most common the most
important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising
whether that be on google search network
or google's display network
you're going to have some common metrics
and here are the metrics that we're
going to focus on today
so you have impressions cost clicks
average cpc
conversions cost per conversion ctr
or click-through rate and quality score
so let's go through these
metrics here and talk about what they
are so impressions
really it's the number of times your ads
been shown
on that particular network whether it's
google search
or display and so an impression is just
how many times
somebody actually seen your ad okay
whether they actually physically seen it
or not if your ad is showing up on that
network
then an impression is going to get
counted so here if we're looking at
ads we can see we have over a period of
time
certain amount of impressions okay so
that's how many times this particular ad
has been shown so this particular ad
here the first one at the top has been
shown
557 times over this period of time which
is year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost
cost refers to the amount of money we've
spent so
any time your ad gets clicked you're
going to pay
google x amount so if i go back to
google ads
i can see what my total cost is and not
only can i see what my total cost is i
can see what my average
cost per click is and so there's a lot
of factors
that go into what you actually pay and
some of these factors are
who else is advertising where you're
advertising
what network you're advertising on what
time of day
what particular keyword and so there's a
lot of factors
and so here i can see on average
year-to-date
i've spent 1.80 per click
on this particular ad for a total of
32.33
so i can really see how much i've
actually spent and so clicks
is just refers to how many times
somebody clicked on your ad so if your
ads been shown you need an
impression and when somebody sees your
ad they're going to click on your ad so
the whole idea is to get the click
remember you want to be in positions one
through three so i want to make sure
that my average position is between
one and three and so if you're looking
in google
ads at metrics and you don't see average
position
well you can always add that as a column
so if i click on
columns here and then i go to
competitive metrics and i click on
average position
and i'm going to move average position
all the way to the top here
so if i click move average position all
the way at the top
i'm going to be able to see what my
average position is
over that particular period of time so
here i can see
i'm in positions one through three and
that's where you wanna be
you wanna be in positions one through
three so if you're in positions one
through three that means you're
at the top if you're on google search or
that means you're
in a problem position on the display
network so if your ad is shown meaning
this gets an impression
then likely somebody's going to click on
that ad and if somebody clicks on that
ad
it's going to generate a click which in
turn is going to generate
cost and so ideally what you want to do
is you want to measure
the rate at which people click on your
ad based on how many times it was shown
so here i can see
28 clicks over 3549
impressions that's a 0.79 click-through
rate so ideally the higher the
click-through rate
the better the at and the higher the
clicker rate the chances are
you're going to get more traffic to your
site so we want to be able to measure
clicks and we want to be able to measure
click through rate and we also want to
measure cost per click which is really
the total cost divided by the number of
clicks so if i go back to google ads
here i can see you know 17.50
over 28 clicks that averages out to
about
63 cents per click so that's how i get
cost per click
now your cost per click is going to vary
a little bit okay so it's going to vary
based on keyword it's gonna be based on
where you're advertising
what position etc so there's a lot of
factors involved with cost per click
but that's how you would actually
calculate it but google ads
actually does a calculation for you for
collector rate
and cost per click but in case you want
to know you can always divide
clicks into cost okay so conversions
probably one of the most important
metrics you're going to use in google
ads because
you're paying google and if you're
paying google for advertising
you want to make sure you're getting
return on your investment so conversions
are added when a user clicks on your ad
and performs an
action that you've defined such as
purchasing something
downloading something viewing something
signing up for a newsletter
etc so you want to make sure that if
you're in google ads
that you're measuring conversions and so
you simply want to go to tools
so if you go to tools and then click on
conversions
you want to make sure that you're
running conversions
ideally what you want to do is you want
to run
conversions from google analytics but
you can certainly set up conversions
within google ads as well
notice i also have call from ads as set
up as a conversion
so you have an opportunity in google ads
to add a number of different conversions
and the more conversions you add really
the better off
you are because you want to measure up
all your campaigns
against conversions if i go back to
campaigns
i want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions
and if i can measure that and i have a
campaign that's really driving
conversions
that i'm going to continue to advertise
on google
okay so here over this particular period
of time i can see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at 128
cost per conversion and so how do i get
cost per conversion
well i get my total cost divided by
the number of conversions and then i
could see my conversion rate the rate at
which people convert
so really if i have 241 clicks and 9
conversions
that's 9 divided by 241 that's 3.77
conversion rate so i can measure
conversion rate
cost per conversion and conversion just
by setting up
conversions in google ads and so ideally
if you're going to pay google for
advertising
you want to be able to measure return on
investment via conversions
so again see cost per conversion is just
really the
the total cost divided by the number of
conversions
and then click the rate again just as a
reminder
the total clicks divided by the total
number of impressions
and then one other metric we're going to
talk about here today
is quality scores so quality score
is really google's way of measuring how
well
your keywords are are compared to
the ad associated with it the expected
click-through rate
and the landing page so quality score is
the backbone of google ads
so if i go back to google ads and i
click on keywords
quality scores something you want to
measure and if you don't have it
in your columns you could certainly just
click on columns and add it and so here
i can see my quality score
and quantity score is a measurement
between 1 and 10 and so
if you have a good quality score google
is going to
score you higher because your keyword is
relevant to your ad
it's relevant to the landing page and
you have a good expected click-through
rate if you don't have a good quality
score
google's going to let you know why you
don't have a good quality score so again
your three categories
that make up quality score are landing
page experience
which means really google looking at the
landing page you're sending people to
and they're seeing if the page loads
well fast
does it have ads does that have good
content is a good landing
page will the end user have a good
experience they also look at the ad
relevance okay is the ad relevant to the
keyword
and they'll also look at the expected
click-through rate okay so based on
other advertisers and their
click-through rate are you
achieving the same click-through rate
and so those three factors
make up quality score quality score is a
metric
assigned to keywords so if you don't
have a good quality score
you need to fix it because the
repercussion is you're going to have to
pay more so having a good quality score
likely means you're going to pay less
per click
so you want to make sure that if you've
bid on a keyword
that the keyword goes to a relevant
landing page
the ad itself is relevant and you're
getting a good click-through rate so
quality score is the backbone of
google ads and how it works so you want
to make sure you have a good quality
score
so optimizing your ads so what if you
don't have a good quality score
what if you're not getting conversions
well there's things you can do
so remember we want to make sure that
we're adding extensions whether that be
call
site link review app add extensions to
your ads because
it's going to increase the click-through
rate so you can also
really hone your ad copy if you're
selling products and you're running
promotion
maybe you want to add in a little sense
of urgency
to help people you know realize hey if
this
this promotion's ending maybe i want to
click on the ad and take action
okay with google ads you can always run
a b testing on ads
and so what you could do is run two ads
in one ad group
and see what ad is performing best in
terms of
click through rate or conversion rate
and whatever ad is running better
you can always run that ad and then
continue more testing so that way you're
always putting your best
forward in terms of advertising and the
ad copy whether that be
text or display you always want to use
call to action
you want to get people to click on your
ad when somebody clicks on your ad
it's going to improve click through rate
click to rate
improves quality score so as i mentioned
several times already you want to make
sure your ads
are placed at the top between positions
one and three
on google search so you can measure ad
position in google ads and if you're not
ranked between one and three you want to
increase your bid
okay you can also optimize for local
search so local
is an ad extension that you can add to
your ad
you can also advertise at a time when
your audience is online
or you can advertise on during business
hours only so you can adjust
when you advertise on google ensure some
of your ads
you know capitalize on some particular
events
that are related to your industry so you
can capitalize on that
okay you can certainly ask google to
accelerate your ads
okay or you can do standard delivery so
google can spread
out your clicks and show your ads
throughout the day
google search is all about keywords so
you want to be able to pick and choose
the right keywords first
you can also add negative keywords so
if you're bidding on a specific industry
let's just say
you have software and you want somebody
to sign up for your
particular piece of software but you
don't offer a free trial then maybe you
want to add
free as a negative keyword so if you
don't offer anything for free
free should be a negative keyword so if
somebody actually does type in
looking for free software then your ads
not going to show up so that's the whole
idea behind negative keywords
okay you can use dynamic keyword
insertion into your ads meaning
you can ask google hey i want to
dynamically insert
a keyword into my ad that somebody uses
to make
your ad more relevant so relevancy
increases click-through rate
and improves quality score so as you can
see there's a lot of things you can do
here's some more things you can use
branded keywords
you can use particular match types in
google
so let's talk about match types for a
second so
you have different match types if i go
back to google ads
here i could see my keywords that i'm
bidding on so
by default if you actually bid on a
keyword
it's going to be broad match and so if
i've been on the keyboard medical
computer
if somebody typed in something related
to medical and included the keyword
medical but not computer
then my ad may show up however i can
make an exact match
so somebody can type in exactly only
medical computers so if i click edit
and i can change the match type for that
particular keyword to exact
then that means that somebody that types
in only medical computer
my ad is going to show up i can
basically do
phrase match so if somebody types in
looking for
something that's going to help me with
medical computers
okay that's a long tail phrase work
keyword query
but the keyword medical computer is in
that order
so my ad is gonna show up okay so with
phrase match
your ad is going to show when somebody
types in that keyword you're bidding on
in that order you also have broad match
modifiers so if you have a plus sign in
front of the keyword
then that means that somebody actually
has to use that keyword
in the query in order for your ad to
show up okay so you could change the
match
type of any keyword so if you use an
exacto phrase
then chances are you're going to have
lower volume of queries
but probably higher relevancy if you use
a broad match
then your ad could show up for any
combination of search queries so you
really want to be careful
on the match type that you choose so
keep an eye on
quality score remember google has
quality score between 1 and 10.
the higher quality score the better you
are so really if you have a quality
score i would say
anything below 4 you probably want to
pause the keyword
okay so you can measure quality score at
the keyword level so if i go back to
google ads
and i have keywords that are say three
chances are i'm going to have to pay
more for the click
and it might not be worth it so i may
want to end up pausing that keyword and
try
other keywords that are more relevant
that i can send traffic to a more
relevant landing page
or i can have an ad that's more relevant
to that keyword in order to help with
the quality score okay you can ensure
that your landing pages
are mobile friendly so that's another
thing you want to keep in mind that most
people
start their search on mobile so you
certainly want to make sure that your
landing pages are optimized
because if somebody starts to search on
mobile likes your products or service
chances are they're coming back via
desktop or even going
into the store most searches start on
mobile so you want to make sure those
pages are optimized
and there's plenty more things you can
do to optimize your ads
you want to make sure you group and
organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write
relevant ads for those keywords so if i
go back to google ads
i want to make sure if i go to ad groups
that the keywords
in that ad group are all relative to one
another so
what's my ad group name well if it's
medical pc
if i click on medical pc i want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group
are all relative to medical pc i want to
structure my campaigns and ad groups to
target more ads
effectively so you want to be able to
you know organize
your campaigns and ad groups and the
rule of thumb here is
you should organize your campaigns and
ad groups based on
the site architecture of your site so
the way
your website is laid out in the
navigation
is how you should likely structure your
campaigns and ad groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to
campaigns that are converting okay you
can use automatic bidding
for ads to maximize results so meaning
that google has
what they call artificial intelligence
so google
can do a lot of the bidding and a lot of
the managing for you that's really a
great
benefit to running your ads on google so
their machines are learning behavior
from your keywords that you're bidding
on and so
ideally when they learn what's
converting
they're going to bid more and try and
help you get the conversion for the
keywords that have historically
converted
and so ideally you can use some of the
automated bidding features that google
ads has to offer in order to
improve performance now google is the
dominant search engine of the web
customers turn to google when they want
to find information
about products and services that means
people are
actively seeking information to show
your ads to active searchers
or people looking for your products and
services you can use
google ads which is google's advertising
program
in this lesson you'll learn how google
ads connects
your business with customers so you can
reach your marketing goals
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to understand
how google ads works discuss the various
targeting methods
and know the primary benefits of using
google ads
that lets you connect your business with
prospective customers
so for instance let's say someone has a
broken pipe in their house
and they want to find a local plumber
they often turn
to google to search for their answers if
you're buying a new house
you might search for real estate or
mortgages or moving companies
all of these are searches that someone
conducts every day
so to reach these searchers you can use
google ads
now google ads is a complex system made
up of multiple networks
targeting options ad formats budget
management and so forth
so we need to take a look at how the
system works
to ensure you're targeting the users who
can turn
into customers now it starts with
picking
targeting methods this could be a user
searching for a keyword in a specific
geography
on a specific device and operating
systems so we'll get more into targeting
methods
as we go through our lessons so you can
write effective ads for those targeting
methods
you set a bid for how much you're
willing to pay if someone clicks on your
ad
now when someone does a search and it
matches your targeting method
then your ad can be displayed so if the
user looks your ad and says yep that's
what i'm looking for
and the user clicks on the ad they go to
your site
now at that moment is when you pay for
the click
or for any action that can happen from
an ad directly
such as calling your company now once
users click in your ads
they go to your site if they take an
action such as
calling your company or buying a product
or filling out a form
or just watching a video then you can
measure those actions
now this lets you see your data for each
targeting method
keyword and add data to understand how
each is performing
now we'll define this information as we
go through our lessons
so you know what to look for to make
data-driven decisions
then from those data driven decisions
you can refine your targeting methods
test different ads and set appropriate
bids
based upon how each click or interaction
is worth to your business
let's say that you're a plumbing company
and you're only in houston texas
so you could target only houston texas
with keywords such as broken pipes
remodeling kitchen and other services
that you conduct
then for each of those keywords you
write an ad
and set a bid if someone is searching
from within houston
for kitchen remodeling they could see
your ad
so if they were searching from austin or
california or seattle
and they're not in your targeting method
they can't
see your ad so it's important to think
about
where are your customers how are they
searching
and then make sure your ads are
compelling and then you can turn those
searchers
into your next customers now the first
network
is known as search this is when someone
inputs a keyword or a search query
into a search engine and then sees
results
there's more than 167 billion searches
a month now then there's another network
that google also supports
known as the display network these are
non-search
places that can show ads so google
display network is made up of more than
three
million websites and apps that encompass
more than one
trillion impressions a month now these
ad placements could be apps on your
phone
or a newspaper publisher site with so
many
possible ad displays your targeting
methods
help narrow down when your ad is
displayed
so you can ensure only those who you
want to see your ad
will see your ad the three primary
targeting methods to think about
initially
our location time of day or day of the
week and device
the location is where our ads are going
to be displayed
this could be every country in the world
it could be a single state it could be
10 states it could be
a radius around your business or your
pin
code you have a lot of control and
options over location targeting the next
we have
time of day and this could be time of
day or even just day of the week so
let's say you have a call center
that's only open from nine to five
monday to friday then you could run your
ads
only during those times nine to five
monday to friday
most companies run their ads all the
time but you can't adjust when they do
run
there are other considerations such as
you're a small
business where you really only answer
your phone from eight to four
so you could only run your ads during
that time now if you're a restaurant
you might want to run your ads later in
the evening to take reservations
you can also choose the device and
operating systems where you want your
ads to run
such as mobile devices tablets computers
or all three
so for example if you're a pizza
delivery place most
pizza orders are now on mobile devices
so while you may be on all devices
mobile is your primary one then you pick
your location
based upon your delivery area and then
finally you choose the time of day for
when your business is open
and actively delivering pizzas now if
you're a large sas company
and you're international your locations
might be
worldwide so we want to think about
breaking down our ads and keywords
by languages or regions so we'll get
more
into how these breakdowns occur in the
account
but a location could be worldwide our
time of day is 24 7
and our devices are just all devices so
you have a lot of control of your
targeting methods
and how people can see your ads both
when and
where keyword is an
object you put into your google ads
account
now a search term or search query
is what a user types into a search
engine to see results
so when this search term matches your
keyword
then your ad can be displayed so if
you're a modeling company
and you do kitchens and bathrooms and
room additions but maybe you don't do
basements
you could pick kitchen modeling keywords
and bathroom modeling keywords
but ignore basement keywords because you
don't do that type of remodeling work
now you can also choose demographics
such as age
gender and income level if you're a
high-end
art dealer you might only sell to the
top 30
of income levels if you're selling
female only clothing
then you could target just females now
in addition we can do things like
behavioral targeting
which is based upon how people use our
websites
this is sometimes known as remarketing
if someone came to your site and they
added items to a shopping cart
but they didn't check out we know
they're almost ready to buy therefore
you could target
those users differently than someone
who's never been to your website
let's say a user searches for accounting
services
on google in maryland in the us
anytime during the week they could see
an ad for a local maryland accountant
now let's say you're on a call center
for mortgage leads and you're only open
on the weekdays
then you can run your ad for the entire
country only during monday to friday
during the hours your call center is
open and only show an
ad if someone searches for mortgage
rates mortgage quotes and so forth
so as we think about our targeting it's
where our customers are
located what they are looking for
the devices they are on and the types of
people we want to serve ads to
now google ads is an auction based
system
you set a bid based upon what you
believe a click
is worth to you and then google looks at
your bid in the relevancy of your ads
and they do this for all the other
advertisers as well then they
order the ads in the search results were
across display properties
based upon both the bid and the
relevancy
now this is an important consideration
as
useful ads are as important as your
bids in determining position so we'll
get into this later when we look at
organization
now it's not just who bids the most that
will get you into position one
is your ad relevant to the user
there's a lot of ways to make things
relevant and we'll walk through this
later
if a user sees your ad you don't pay
anything
only if a user clicks on your
ad do you pay the search engine that's
why it's called
pay per click advertising is you only
pay when someone clicks on the ad
now you can then measure results such as
acquired customers return on ad spend
revenue and so forth
now based upon the results you're
receiving from google ads
you can then refine your ads or change
your bids
based upon what those clicks are worth
to you
when we think about the google ads
benefits we often call them
the three r's reach relevance
roi now from a reach standpoint google
search and the display networks have
tremendous reach
they can help you reach your target
audience because your target audience is
probably using google whether it's on
search or display or both
so the advertising system has the reach
that encompasses
your potential customers the next think
about
relevance this is a big thing in
advertising
are you relevant to the users
right searches are often resistant to
ads that's why if you're watching tv and
a commercial appears
you might hit the fast forward button or
switch the channel when the ad is
relevant users like ads they'll
interact with them if they're useful and
they're relevant
so you can target users based upon many
criteria
which means your ad should be relevant
to users
especially on search when you pick
keywords
that represent your business as someone
is actively searching for that word that
means
they're looking for a solution so when
users see relevant ads
they're more likely to click and do
business with your company
now finally we have roi known as return
on investment
as our third benefit returner ad spend
row os or roi
let us know how profitable a channel
is now as you can measure results from
your ad spend
you can make data driven decisions based
upon how
users interact with your ads and how
they're becoming customers
so google ads has the reach that
encompasses your users
when you make good accounts and you have
good account structure
which we'll get into later videos you
can ensure your ad is
relevant to users so they'll click on
the ads
and come to your website so you can turn
them into customers
now with analytics and conversion
tracking you can see exactly
how much that person's worth to you so
then you can adjust your reach
and your relevance data to ensure that
your return on investment is fantastic
from using
google ads as a marketing channel so
google
ads accounts have multiple levels of
structure
in order for you to be able to control
how users can
view interact with your ads along with
your budget and bid controls
now in this lesson we'll examine each
level of hierarchy
so you can understand how average
accounts fit together
and how data flows throughout your
accounts so by the end of this lesson
you're able to understand account level
settings
understand campaign targeting options
and discuss the purpose of an
ad group so when we look at the overall
account hierarchy
it starts where we have an account then
an account can be made
of one or more campaigns then each
campaign
can have one or more ad groups and then
finally
ad groups are a collection of ads and
keywords so as we look at accounts
campaigns and
ad groups each level has different items
you set with it so we're going to look
individually
at each of these items to see how you
can use
various settings at each level now at
the account level
we have several options that we can set
the first is account
access this is who can log in and access
your data
so when you open an account you'll use a
google account
the list doesn't have to be a gmail
address you can make your own email
address for your company
a google account and then use that for
login purposes
but then you can give others access to
your account as well
from a security standpoint it's useful
just to have
one administrator who gives access
levels to other individuals
that way if someone leaves your company
or no longer needs access to your data
you can disable just that access point
instead of using
shared account logins then you'll also
choose your time zone
now some items such as time zone and
currency cannot be changed
once you open the account so you pick
your time zone
and when you think about it you it's
useful to have your
analytics your server and your marketing
such as your google ads account
on the same time zone now because if
you've got an
ads account in pacific time and your
servers on eastern time
there's a three hour period of time a
day when your data doesn't
agree with each other so it's useful to
sync servers
google ads account analytics so forth
into a single time zone
now you'll also choose your currency do
you want to be billed in euros or
dollars or pounds or canadian dollars
and so forth
again currency can't be changed once
you've set up your account as well
and then you have billing how are you
going to pay for the clicks that you
accrue
and then you can connect other accounts
to your google ads account
such as google analytics google merchant
center firebase etc
so if you're using multiple systems you
can connect them
all together at the account level so
they can all use the same data
and then you have notification settings
how do you want to be notified
of suggestions or disapproved ads and so
forth
in some preferences like display
language
number formats etc so that when you open
an account
the two most important options really to
think about though are time zone and
currency
they can't be changed you can change
your billing later on or you can change
whose account access some preferences
but time zone and currency are set once
your account is open
let's look at the campaign settings you
have an account
an account can be made up of one or more
campaigns
so a campaign setting is where you're
going to tell google ads
how to show the ads and keywords within
that campaign
so first we have the network do you want
to be on search network
display network or potentially both and
when you're first starting
search is the best place to start
because users are actively
looking for solutions so you could have
one campaign that searched
and another campaign that is displayed
now we choose our devices at the
campaign level as well
so it might be on all devices we could
be on just mobile devices or just
computers or just tablets
if we want to run our ads at certain
times of day
or day of the week we also set those and
the campaign settings
so if you only want your ads to run
monday to friday you can choose those
options at the campaign level
now is say you want your brand terms to
run all the time
and then you have other keywords you
only want to run monday to friday
then you can use two campaigns campaigns
can have different settings from each
other
so you could have one campaign for your
legion keywords that runs monday to
friday
clicks go to a call center you can maybe
have another campaign
that's brand terms that runs all seven
days of the week and they're
in another campaign so that way you can
segment out
which items run when now locations are
also set up at the campaign setting
so if you're a multi-location business
you've got one location in houston
another in seattle another in new york
and you only want to run ads in those
geographies
you could either put one campaign
together and target all three of those
locations single campaign
now all those locations would use the
same ads and keywords
or you can make a campaign for each
location
if you make a campaign by location then
any other settings such as time of day
or budgets
which use campaign settings can be
customized for each location
your bid method is also a campaign
setting
so with bid methods at a high level
there's two
types one's manual where you set the bid
yourself
and another is automated where you're
setting a goal for the system and the
system is bidding on your behalf
and then you have budget how much you're
willing to spend on a daily basis
so if you have one location and you want
to spend
100 a day and then you have another
location
where you want to spend 500 a day that
would be two
different campaigns so you can have
different budgets
for each of the campaigns so when you
want a
campaign level setting to be different
for some reason
a set of keywords location or something
else
that's one of the reasons to make a
different campaign
so if you want certain ads to run only
in certain locations
only certain times a day if you have
budgets by product line
you use different campaigns to control
those items
so when you think about budget
management if you want a different
budget
by product line you make each product
line
its own campaign so when we think about
search
here's a couple examples of how we might
set up campaigns
you might have one campaign it's on
search it's on all devices
it's only set to the country of say the
united states
it uses an automated bid system that can
spend a hundred dollars a day
you might have another campaign it's on
search
it's only on desktops it's set to france
it's based on manual bidding it has a 50
a day budget so when you want these
campaign level settings to be
different that's one of the main reasons
to create a new campaign
for the ads and keywords that are inside
of that campaign
now ad groups are a collection of
keywords and ads
and only an ad from that ad group that
contains the same
keyword that matched to a search query
right can be displayed
so ad groups should be closely related
collections
of keywords and ads so we think about
the work involved and setting up a
google ads account it's really quick
just to make an account it can be very
quick to make a campaign
but where you're going to slow down and
spend your time
is thinking about your ad groups someone
did a search they are looking for
something
they're going to then see an ad so that
ad is going to take them to a page of
your website
so you want that user experience be very
cohesive
so you may have one campaign the
campaign could have
20 or 50 or a thousand ad groups in it
right for each type of idea that you're
advertising
so if you want to show a user a
different
ad based upon their search term changing
you want a different ad group let's say
we sell shoes
now we sell hiking boots we sell running
shoes we sell dress shoes
now we don't want to do is put all of
those in one ad group
because if someone searches for hiking
boots versus
a running shoe versus a dress shoe
you want a different ad there's not a
good that explains
all those concepts so we could write an
ad
shoes for sale right but shoes for sale
doesn't really speak to the user
if someone's doing a search for hiking
boots
right and they see an end that says
shoes for sale and another ad that says
hiking boots for sale
right walk on the trails comfortably
right
they're gonna look at the one that says
choose for sale and say
it's not relevant to what i'm looking
for and the ad that mentioned
the product they search for hiking boots
would be relevant we get a lot more of
those clicks and conversions
so why we may take some keywords like
hiking boots
trail hiking boot hiking boots for sale
best hiking boots
and put them in an ad group together
right we make an
ad only for those keywords so we create
and add hiking boots for sale walk the
trails in comfort
but then someone searches for running
shoes that ad would
not be a good result for them right
hiking boots an ad that
they're looking for running shoes so
you'd want a different
ad group for running shoes so you might
have keywords
running shoes best running shoes shoes
for running marathon long distance
running shoes
right and then we can make an ad that
says running shoes for sale
maximize your performance now if we were
really focused on running shoes
and that was our core business then we
wouldn't want to run just a running shoe
ad because that's very general
we want to get more specific if
someone's running a marathon
they want long distance running shoes
others want
minimalistic running shoes you'll see
see people search for running shoes with
high arches
or better arch support wide box shoes
since you can even get into those very
specific terms to create
ads for them in the ad groups when you
think about
ad group structure only the keywords in
that
ad group can show for that ad
right if we have two ad groups and
someone searches for running shoes
right they can't see our hiking boots ad
because it's in a different ad group
they only see the running shoes at
so you can make multiple ads in an ad
group and do some ad testing
to see which is best so if we look at an
ad group and we see here's another
keyword that we really want to look at
and the ads we have
aren't great for that keyword we can
move it to a new ad group
so we may have one ad group set stress
shoes another for
high heels and we can make new adders
for all of these items
so that the ad and then where the user
goes on your website or
is specific to each of those types that
idea of keywords
so you might have many aggregates but
the trick about ad groups
is you have a core set of keywords in
each ad group
and then you have multiple ads in an ad
group and so as long as
all the ads and the keywords are
reflective of each other
then you've got a good ad group now if
an ad does not represent
a keyword that keyword should be in a
different ad group
settings are inherited downwards across
the account
so for instance the account level you
set billing the billing methods used by
all the campaigns in the account
and all the ad groups so you set access
level by account so anyone with account
access level can see are your campaigns
in ad groups so then at the campaign
level
we enter settings like budgets location
so that goes from the campaign level
is inherited down to the ad groups so
any ad group in the campaign that can
show to all the users in a location
that's set at the campaign level or
budgets and so forth
so then that goes from campaign is
inherited to the ad groups so any ad
group in the campaign can
show where it may reach the campaign
settings such as location or it uses
that same budget
where all the aggregate campaign use a
budget so if we have
different campaigns then only the ad
groups in that campaign
would use that campaign's budget and
that campaign's targeting
method so when you create a setting at
the account level
it's used at the campaign level and then
anything at the campaign level
is used at the ag group level so if you
create ad group level settings for
something
you can set up the ad group they're only
used by the ads and
keywords in that specific ad group ad
group data is never
inherited to another ad group so
setting hierarchy flows downwards across
the account from account to campaign to
ad group
and then the ads and keywords so the
first step to getting started with
google ads
is opening an account now once you open
an account
then you can fill in your billing
information add additional users
and connect your analytics account to
your google ads account
so in this lesson we will look at how to
create the initial account
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to open
a google ads account set permission
levels
and user access data and then connect
additional accounts
now before you begin creating a google
ads account
you'll need a google account to access
it
if you use gmail then you can use your
gmail
account if you want to use your business
email
then you can create an account and use
your business
email address you'll need to verify your
account through a text message code or
through an email to the email address
you're using to access your google ads
account now once you've established
how to access your google ads account
proceed to setting up
your first campaign each person who can
access
your data should have their own login
this lets you choose their permission
level remove
someone when they should no longer have
access and see what changes were made
in the change history tool which logs
changes by user access
before adding a user you should consider
the permission
level that the user needs so for
instance
if you want someone to see information
but not change anything
you can give them read only access
if you want a user to be able to make
any changes
but not add or move other users they can
have standard access
by giving each user access you can
maintain control
over your data and also add and remove
other users as your need for accessing
your data changes
there are times when you will want your
google ads account
to connect with other applications so
they can share data back and forth
this is really common with google
analytics
by connecting google analytics and
google ads
you can see a lot of data in both places
in addition you can create conversions
or
audience lists in google analytics and
have them
imported into google ads if you're an
e-commerce company
then you want to create a google
merchant center account
and link it to your google ads account
so you can create shopping campaigns
a common problem you might come across
is that one email
is the admin for one account and another
email is the admin for your google ads
account
you might need to give someone
permission to log
into google ads to connect accounts or
they might need to give
you permission to access the accounts
that you want to link to google ads
so you have the necessary permission
levels in both places
to connect the data once you have the
necessary permissions in place
it's easy to connect other accounts to
your google ads account
using the linked accounts tool inside of
your google ads account
so i want you to imagine having the
world at your fingertips
especially when it comes to advertising
imagine having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising
so just imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to any
website in the world can you imagine
that
well imagine having that entirety
at your fingertips the entire world so
it's not
really an imagination so no need to
imagine
anymore because google ads
has come to the rescue so no need to
imagine the world is at your fingertips
and why is it at your fingertips because
of
google and specifically google display
network okay so we're gonna talk about
what the google display network is so
let's start out by
asking the question or answering the
question what is the google display
network
so google has two networks basically
one the search network one the display
network so you as an advertiser
if you want to advertise on google you
have a choice
can i go with google search or can i go
with the display network well
the search network is for google search
only
so if you want to advertise when
somebody types in a keyword query and
you want your ad to show up
that's the search network so it looks
something like this somebody types in a
keyword
data science and lo and behold ads show
up
and here you can see the first ad from
simply learn why did that ad show up
because
simply learn was bidding on the keyword
data science
and so that's how the search network
works you bid on keywords somebody types
on those keywords and your ads show up
in the search engine results at the top
above organic listings
so that's the search network and it just
simply comprises
of ads that respond to what people are
querying
okay the display network is a little bit
different so
that's the search network today we're
going to talk about the display network
okay the display network is a little bit
different so
imagine you're on the lookout for a new
shoe on amazon as an example
but you don't have end up buying the
shoe you're looking at shoes
you don't buy it well you might have
noticed
in the past you've done something like
that whether it be shoes
or shirts or coats or belts or
cars or radios or headphones or
phones it doesn't really matter you
might have been looking at something
and then notice an ad show up it might
have been exactly that same product or
might have been something
similar to the product you were looking
at but on the same website
so why does that happen well it happens
because
google's display network specifically
remarketing which we'll talk about
so on google's display network you have
the option to
advertise that somebody's been on your
website so that's one of the powers and
one of the features
of google's display network and that's
remarketing or retargeting
somebody that's looked at your product
so let's take a little bit
of a deeper dive into how the display
network works
so if you're a customer you go to a
website
and you leave that website again from a
remarketing perspective
your product can appear on another site
okay so that's remarketing so you can
retarget that person who's been to your
site so that's
again one great example of how to use
display network
in google terms we call it remarketing
and again somebody goes to your website
they leave in this example not buying
something
it could be a technology company where
we want somebody to watch a video or
download
a pdf okay whatever they do that
that you want them to do but they don't
actually do it then you can go back and
retarget them so if they actually
go to a page and look at your product
but don't buy that product
then you have the opportunity to
advertise to them again
so the whole idea is if you advertise
them again
wow that person can say okay i remember
that i was in
still interested in that product let me
go back and purchase that product
so they go back to the site and make the
purchase so that's again the power of
the display network you can reach
people who have been to your site before
so let's take another look here
so retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code
or pixel on your website which uses
browser cookies to add website visitors
to your audience so
let me just summarize that for you so if
you want to use display network
and you want to target people who've
been to your website well you need to
add a simple
script or pixel if you will to your
website that's all
and so when somebody comes to your
website they're gonna get cookied and
that cookie
is stored in their browser and so that's
an important piece of the whole process
because
that's how google determines who that
visitor is so without that
cookie then google won't know to show
their ad
your ad to them again so that's the
first piece in all this
so when somebody does get cookie they're
going to be added to that audience
and so when we say audience we mean you
as an advertiser defining who you want
to retarget to
so in this example we're talking about
people who've looked at a product and
didn't purchase
that could be a whole audience in itself
people who
look at a product and don't purchase it
could be everyone who comes to your
website it could be only return users
it could be only new users you defund
the audience
but however you define that audience
they're going to get cookied and placed
on a list and when they're placed in
that list they're going to get shown the
ad again
so past visitors will see your product
ads when they're browsing the web
watching videos on youtube going through
news sites and so on
so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where they're going to
be able to see your ad
because google's displayed network is
much more than just websites it's also
youtube
it's also news feeds it's also social
networking sites so there's a lot
involved with google's display network
so the network involves several websites
that are partnering up with google
along with the likes of youtube along
with the likes on millions of other
websites
in fact these websites together tally up
to more than
2 million that encompasses more than 90
of the internet so you can imagine
google's display network is just
made up of a bunch of websites including
youtube
okay so you have the opportunity to
really reach somebody that's been to
your website before
so again if they're past visitors and
they looked at a product and they didn't
purchase it
you have an opportunity to really put
your ad in front of them
on a lot of different websites so that's
just an
intro about the display network
remarketing is just
one benefit but let's take a step back
so we dove into the deep end with
remarketing let's just separate out the
two again
just so you're clear on what the display
network is
versus the search network well let's go
some through some of the differences
so display network on the left search
network on the right
so the display network as we just
discussed
is great for retargeting people who have
been to your website
whether they're new users returning
users users who looked at a product
users who added a product to your cart
users who looked at a specific page
whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network
is usually for top of funnel why do we
say top of funnel because
users are actively searching for
something they're looking for a product
they're being
active so they're going to search and
seeing who has that product
okay the display network we know
remarketing is a benefit but usually
it's bottom of funnel like brand
awareness so
if nobody knows who your brand is or
what your brand is or what you have to
offer what your services are
then the display network remember made
up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display bottom of
funnel search network top of funnel
somebody
actively looking for something let's
take a look at some other differences
here
so display network easier to advertise
products that don't satisfy an immediate
need
this is true because again if you have a
new product you want to get that product
out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least
they're going to know what the products
about on the search network on the other
hand
if somebody's looking for something like
a particular product that you're
offering
then they could type in a keyword that
describes that product
and when your ad can appear at the top
okay remember top of funnel so products
and services usually fulfill a
particular requirement
now the display network can be used to
familiarize users
to your brand so again going back to
remarketing
somebody comes to your website they
really don't know who you are well
you can reach back out to them on the
display network
with another ad retargeting and that's
how you get users familiar with your
brand where on the search network users
are showing ads based on what they
search for
so it doesn't really matter if they know
your brand or not
hey if they're looking for something
they're ready to buy and you have that
product at the right price
then the chance of them converting are
pretty good so you're at the right place
at the right time
where the display network's all about
familiarity retargeting to people with
your brand getting your brand out there
getting your product out there in front
of millions of people
now on the display network users are
shown these ads in over a million
different websites so
with the display network you have the
opportunity to kind of hone in and pick
and choose those websites
where on the search network users are
shown ads
in google apps and on the search engines
so you have the opportunity to place
your ads not just on
desktop search but also on mobile and
also
on apps whereas again the display
network is made up
of much more it's made up of websites
youtube apps etc okay the display
network
has a multitude of different formats
okay when we say different formats we
mean
text ads image ads rich media ads
meaning ads that have some functionality
to it like movement
okay and then video ads where the search
network is really
only text ads and i say really only text
ads well you can
have image ads those are called shopping
ads but
mainly it's text ads where display
network you have an
option between text image rich media or
video edit so you can see the
differences here really there are
big differences between the two networks
where search you're just really
responding what somebody's looking for
they're really active and ready to go
display
hey you're trying to reach out to these
people you're trying to introduce them
to something and in some cases with
remarketing you're reaching out to them
again okay you're trying to get them
familiar with your product and brand and
you're trying to do that
via video via rich media via a regular
image ad
via text ad so you're trying to do it in
a multitude of formats so again
bottom of funnel for display top of
funnel
for search so that's an intro to the
display network those are the
differences between
search and display now let's go through
the steps of how to set up
a campaign in google ads
using the display network as our option
so here i am
i'm in google ads i'm in an account and
i want to set up
a campaign on the display network so you
could see here if i'm in google ads i've
selected display campaigns i can already
see
i have some display network campaign set
up in fact they're all remarketing
campaigns
so remarketing remember is targeting
somebody who fits
a list or description okay so it could
be somebody looking
at a particular product they get cookie
meaning that
text file is gonna sit on their browser
and then they're gonna see your ad
the next time you're on google's display
network wherever site they may be
so we're reaching out to somebody who
fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display
campaign meaning a campaign on google's
display network
we want to go to campaigns and we want
to click on the plus button here
and we're just going to say new campaign
now we have the opportunity now to
pick and choose what our goal is for
that campaign and so
most of the time with display you're
going to choose brand awareness and
reach
okay so here you can see the campaign
types for brand awareness and reach
display and video usually when it comes
to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search network but
if you're just really trying to just
promote your brand
you may go with display because remember
you have the option to get your ad in
front of millions of websites
we're gonna choose brand awareness and
reach okay and we're going to choose the
campaign type
so here you have display we want to run
different kinds of ads
or we can run just video okay we want to
run if we're running video we can
reach and engage viewers on youtube and
across the web meaning other websites
okay let's choose display here so
we're gonna go ahead and just put our
website in there
so our businesses website and
when that loads up we're gonna have a
number of different options available to
us
so here we can name our campaign okay so
here you can see brand awareness and
reach
is the name of our campaign and for now
we're just going to protest
now we have the opportunity to choose
our location here we're going to choose
the united states
we have just like a search campaign we
also have languages and options so with
search you have locations and languages
same thing on display so we're going to
target english as our language
and what are we trying to do what are we
focusing on well
we want to get a product out there so
we're going to choose
impressions viewable impressions that's
really what we want to focus on we want
people
to see our ad okay so an impression is
the number of times somebody sees your
ad okay so
we have viewable impressions that's what
we want people to do we want them to see
our ad
and if you take a peek over here on the
right side
you can see your targetings reach so we
can reach over
10 billion plus in impressions meaning
that's a lot of eyeballs
the number of people looking at our ad
right now is over 10
billion plus okay so that's just gives
you the scope and some idea of how big
google's display network is so just like
search we could set a budget
i'm just gonna choose a hundred dollars
for now and i can
choose how to deliver that budget just
like on search
i have standard accelerated i can ask
google to speed up the spend
or i could just do regular standard
which means they're going to spend my
budget
evenly over a period of time over the
course of the day
now remember with display network we
have
different options on ad types we have
text ads
rich media ads regular image ads and
video so we can rotate
our ads how we like so we could say hey
look i want to
run my best performing ads okay so that
means i want google to optimize for me
meaning if i have an ad that's
performing better than some others
then i'm going to let google run that
one more and that's the one i would
recommend but you do have other options
here you can just have them rotate
evenly
you can say hey optimize for conversions
but it's really
remember our goal here for display is to
get impressions eyeballs we're not
interested in top of funnel conversions
and here we could say rotate evenly and
that's not supported for display so
really
our best option here is prefer best
performing ads we want our best
performing ads to run okay we have an
option to schedule them we have an
option to start and okay and we have an
option to set a cap
how many times we want somebody to look
at that ad so we can limit how many
times our ad is shown to the same
user okay so we're going to let google
optimize how often your ads are shown
however we do have the option to set
that limit okay so we could set the
limit to
x times per day for the entire campaign
or it could be for a particular ad or
aggro okay so we could set the limit
ourselves and we can let google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions
okay and then we have the opportunity to
set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
network the ad group
on display is where your settings are
going to be your ads are going to be
located in your ad group and now the
important part we want to get to
audiences so
if we're remarketing we're going to
choose our audience
and if we're not remarketing we still
have the opportunity
to choose our audience so if i'm a tech
company and i just type in tech
then google is going to give me some
options here so here i can choose some
tech companies
technology client products new
inventions
etc or i can choose some ideas that
google has
in mind for audiences like they have an
in-market audience
so this is based on network systems and
services
network management so the bottom line is
google is giving me suggestions
on who i can target my ad to okay that's
what really what this
is choosing your audience now you don't
have to choose anything here
in fact you can just clear all and be
done with it now you can go down to
demographics now i can pick and choose
based on gender
i can pick and choose based on age
parental status
and household income really depending on
who you're advertising to
that's really what it comes down to it
okay so you have demographics and you
have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go
with some of google's recommended
audiences or you can create your own
audience
and we're going to talk about that here
in a minute but this is all
part of the setup for the campaign so
i'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not
remarketing you don't necessarily have
to go with an audience okay once that's
done
you can set up a bid just like you want
on the search network and then you have
the option
to choose your app so that's part of the
campaign setup so when you actually
choose your ad
again you have different options image
ad okay rich media ad
video or text once you choose your ad
then you pretty much have your campaign
set up now we're gonna
tweak it after we set it up but that's
pretty much the steps in terms of
setting up a display campaign
very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience
and choosing the ad type that's really
the main differences between setting up
a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences
now there are other subtle differences
but those are the main ones so
we talked about remarketing to people
who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they looked at a product or they
looked at a particular page
so if you're going to retarget the
people then as a best practice
i would set up the audience in google
analytics so
google analytics talks to google ads in
fact
you can link up the two in analytics so
regardless of whether you're
creating a display campaign or search
campaign
you want to link up analytics with
google ads
so you can see we've done that here okay
now that we've linked the two up
we could set up an audience in google
analytics
for use on a remarketing campaign on
google's display network
so here you can see i have audiences set
up if you want to just create a new
audience you can do that
so if i click new audience here here i
can choose choose
returning users or new users these are
audiences that google has set up
by default i can create a new one if i
want so i could say hey
i want to target you know 18 to 24 year
old males
who speak english for example
and who came from mobile so
if i go here technology i'm going to say
including mobile so that could be my
audience so anybody who fits that
description
of 18 to 24 year old coming to my
website from mobile
who speaks english i'm going to retarget
them and you can go ahead and save this
so if i go ahead and click apply i'm
gonna name my audience
18 24 year old male english
mobile one thing about remarketing on
the display network
is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live
so depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car
the funnel may be six months long if
they're buying a pair of shoes the
funnel may be seven days long maybe even
shorter so it really depends on your
business the default is 30 days
so if you go with 30 days and that means
any 18 to 24 year old male
who speaks english and comes from mobile
is going to get cookied and that cookie
is going to live for 30 days
so if i click next step i can go ahead
and publish it
i can say i want this to be available in
my google ads account so i'm going to go
ahead and pick my account
and it'll be available in that account
so i'll choose my account
and then go ahead and click publish so
now this
audience list is going to be available
for me to use
in my display campaign when i go to
choose my audience
so if i go back to google ads so google
ads and google analytics talk to one
another why because they're linked
and so now when i go to actually set up
my ad group and i'm choosing remarketing
i can go ahead and choose that audience
list so for example
this campaign that's already set up i
can go ahead and choose
to set up another ad group with that
particular audience list
so if i choose new ad group and now i'm
going to search
for the audience i just set up so here
you go i just did a search
and here's my audience i'm going to
select my audience
and i'm going to now use this audience
in
my ad group for my remarketing campaign
so
now all i need to do is align the right
ad
with this audience so that's how
remarketing works
you choose your audience list you set up
your ads remember you have different ad
formats video rich media image and text
and the whole idea beyond remarketing is
you know who your audience is
you know what you want to say to them so
your ads
should really encompass that message
the message of what you want to say to
that particular group in this case
18 to 24 year old male who speak english
who came to your site from mobile so if
you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the display network to your
advantage
remember bottom of the funnel the goal
of our campaign
is just get our ad out there so that
people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go
to set up an ad group you don't have to
choose an audience to retarget to
you do have other options so if i look
at this ad group here
you can see i have image ads already set
up so where do i want these
image ads to appear so i do have options
available to me
in the display network so if i choose
keywords
then that means if i go ahead and add a
keyword
then what google is going to do is
contextually place
my image ad on a website that fits the
description
or matches that keyword so if i add one
or two or three keywords
then what google is going to do is going
to look at that keyword and it's going
to map
a website on the display network using
those keywords
so that's keywords now you got to be
careful here because
it's a broad way of advertising meaning
your ads could appear on sites that you
don't necessarily
deem relevant to those keywords so
you're allowing google
to match the website with the keywords
you choose
so that's choosing keywords audiences
again
audiences are there if you want to
retarget so if you're retargeting
you can set up your audience in
analytics in fact that's the best
practice
so again if i go back to analytics and i
go back to admin
under my property audiences i can go
ahead and choose my audience to be used
in google ads so
that's using audiences on a display
campaign
on google's display network when we're
setting up our campaign we had
an option to choose demographics so we
can exclude a demographic if we wanted
to
we can always go back and exclude a
demographic just by
removing them from the ad group notice
if we choose all demographics we can
actually then see over a period of time
in google ads how many people based on
this
particular age group or gender or
parental status or household income
saw our ad but not only saw our ad
that wouldn't be impressions but clicked
on our ad and how much they spent
per click and how many conversions so
you have all that data available to you
in the display network okay so that's
demographics
i can also use topics so i can take
i can choose a particular topic to
advertise on
so if i choose topics i can choose a
particular keyword
find a particular topic or i can drill
down
on google's topic categories and
subcategories
so here you can see online communities
if i choose that one i could see there
are other
subcategories under online communities
okay i can choose the whole category of
science or i can drill down
to see what subcategories are under
science so i can do that for any one of
these
topic categories and if i choose a
category
notice that's where google is going to
place my ad whatever i select
again notice upper right here i can take
a sneak peek at
how many eyeballs google is expecting
to see my ad so here by choosing
astronomy and science
i have 310 million impressions that's
how many potential eyeballs
can look at my ad so if you're setting
up a display
network campaign you can choose keywords
you can choose demographics or you can
choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
a topic
then your last option here is placements
so i can pick and choose a specific
placement if there's a particular
website that i want to advertise on
let's just say newyorktimes.com or or
latimes.com or webmd.com
remember there are over two million
websites on google's display
network so i can pick and choose
specifically
where i want my ads to be displayed now
when you're done choosing your audience
or your keywords
or your demographics your topics or your
specific placements
you can always then go to your
placements and then click on
where ads showed and so now over this
particular time frame
i'm going to be able to see where my ads
have been shown
and so now i can see my ads have been
shown
by mobile apps and on particular
websites
now if you don't like any of the
particular websites that your ad is
showing on
you can always select it and you can
always
exclude it can exclude it from the ad
group or the campaign okay so that's how
you
manage where your ads are showing up on
google's display network again you can
go ahead and go to where ads are shown
under placements and over that
particular period of time
google's going to show you where your
ads been shown and if you don't like
that placement
then you can always just exclude it or
if you don't like
the performance meaning you're not
getting many impressions or you're not
getting many clicks or the click-through
rates very low
you can go ahead and exclude it so this
is an opportunity for you the advertiser
to take control over where your ads are
shown so in summary
when you set up a display campaign on
google's display network
you have options if you're remarketing
you're going to choose your audience
gonna choose your audience using a list
you created in google analytics if
you're on the display network
not remarketing you have the option you
can choose a keyword
and have google place your ad on a
website that fits the description of
that keyword
you could choose specific demographics
you could choose a topic or subtopic
category
or you could choose a specific placement
okay those are all the options available
to you
when you run your ad on google's display
network now
let's go back and take a look at some of
the advantages
of the google display network so i just
went over with you
how to actually create a campaign in an
ad group i
actually went over how to set up a
marketing campaign
and set up a marketing list and
analytics and i went over
all the differences between the search
network and display but
let's really hone in on those advantages
here so
with the display network we can provide
advanced
targeting meaning i can particularly
point to a specific website that i want
to advertise on so that's what i mean by
advanced targeting or
if i don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds i can
exclude them or
i can really pick and choose a specific
audience that i want to remarket to so
those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done within
analytics or google ads so advanced
targeting
enables you to target the people that
didn't engage with previous campaigns
and get in front of people with
look-alike audiences that can be created
based on the audience you usually
advertise to
so in other words we can really hone in
and pick and choose who we want to
advertise to another advantage is
relatively
low starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost
is normally on the search network you're
bidding on keywords and some keywords
can be
very competitive whereas on the display
network
you can pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose where
you want to advertise
so you can really advertise on websites
that get a lot of traffic
may not have a lot of competition and
therefore may not cost as much
so if you compare it to traditional
forms of advertising like tv or radio
display advertising reaching a large
broader audience
is a lot cheaper okay you can do
advanced tracking
meaning when we talk about perform
advanced tracking
we're talking about again remarketing we
can really pick
and choose who we want to remarket to
and cookie them and pick and choose
how long they are going to be cooking so
we talk about advanced tracking that's
what we're really talking about
so we can also talk about how many times
our ad is shown to somebody we really
can pick and choose
how many times we want somebody actually
see our ad on a site
based on performance okay let's take a
look at some other advantages the
ability to advertise your
brand to a broader audience and google
has over two million websites
so we can pick and choose where really
where we want our ads to show up
again it can be by topic it could be
contextually via keywords or it can be
specific
websites so we can create demand for our
product
and what we mean by that we can create
really cool
ads remember rich media ads video ads
these are all
engaging type of ads those are ad types
on the display network
we create engaging type of ads it's
going to appeal to somebody and they're
going to engage
so we have that opportunity just based
on the different ad types
of course increasing web traffic we
can't say that enough
if you're advertising on google's
display network you have the opportunity
to get your ad in front of millions of
people
get up front our ads in front of
millions of people we have the
opportunity to get a lot of clicks
and we do have that wide range of
formats
search network only has text ads here we
have text
we have rich media we have image we have
video so all these
types of ad formats allow us to really
get our ads out there in a number of
different ways
again we're marketing our products and
services of the big
big big advantage using google's display
network that's how we started today's
webinar we started talking about
remarketing because it's such
a key feature so if somebody comes to
our website and doesn't do it
we want them to do we can cookie them
and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailored to
that audience today we're going to talk
about google analytics
i'm very excited to be with you today
because google analytics
is one of my favorite google platforms
and my favorite topics so
let's talk about what we're going to
cover today and we're going to start out
with
how to set up a google analytics account
and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account
and what a property is we're going to
talk about setting up a reporting view
in your property
and we're going to talk about installing
the tracking code so those are the
series of steps we're going to go
through today
in terms of setting up a google
analytics account
so let's get right to it and so really
the
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a google analytics account
is to have a google login and id so when
you actually go
to google analytics you need to be able
to
sign up or sign in and so once you
actually
sign in then you're gonna go walk
through a series of steps
but really that's really all you need to
get
the account going is a google id and
login
so if you have a gmail account or
another
email account that you use for other
google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for
google analytics you're going to be
asked to
set up a new account and these are the
series of steps you're going to walk
through or go through to set up a new
google analytics account so you're going
to choose an account name
and then you're going to choose a
property name okay so the account name
can be anything you want it to be
the name your company your name whatever
you want to name it
the property name is really the website
name so
what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name
for now it's called demo simply learn so
the url for this website demo simply
learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics
we're really talking about what websites
we want to measure
and then you're going to be asked to
choose an industry category
and so for simply learn we're in jobs
and education
but you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most
relevant industry that your particular
business is associated with okay and i'm
gonna
talk about why that's important here in
a minute and then you're gonna choose
your time zone
and the time zone is also important
because
that's when the day starts in analytics
then the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that google
analytics collects
starts and ends with that time zone so
very important
to choose the time zone your business is
located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so
you have some settings and so the first
setting is
to allow google products and services so
if you opt into this then basically
what google's gonna do is share some
products and services
with you via email i would go ahead and
opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt
to hear from google on related products
and services that
may enhance your business the second is
benchmarking
so benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into
so going back to that industry and
category we chose jobs and education
so by opting into benchmarking basically
what google is going to do
is share your data that it collects on
your website
in this case demo.simplylearn.com it's
going to share
that data anonymously with
others in the industry in this case jobs
and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to
do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share
anonymous data on other websites in
the same industry and the benefit of
that is
we get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the benchmark
in our industry and so the benchmarking
to me
is important and i'm gonna go over that
in a few minutes when we go over the
different reports but to me i would
always
opt into benchmarking because this is
the only report
google provides in analytics about how
others in your industry is performing
versus your website okay so it's a
way to compare your website performance
against others in the same industry
the other options here technical support
and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you
to basically google allow google access
to your account
and they'll be able to help you if you
occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up
a google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few fields
note that
we talking about a website right now so
i'm talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app
google analytics will allow you to do
that as well you just choose the option
mobile app so we're tracking a website
we want to know how users behave when
they get to my website and that's what
google analytics
is going to allow us to measure and look
at we just need to do a couple more
steps
in the process so once we fill out these
fields here
we're going to click get tracking id now
i'm going to accept the terms of service
i'm going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
i'm going to click accept once i accept
i'm going to be able to get
some tracking code the tracking id is
the id
associated with your account and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account
id starts with ua and it's gonna be
this number here now the dash one is the
property
you set up so in this case i set up demo
demo.simplylearn.com
if i wanted to track multiple websites
under that same account then i can
certainly set up multiple properties
just know that every property i set up
in that account
is going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up
so by default i set up one property so
my first property id is dash one if i
set up a second property
the same account number it's just gonna
have a dash two
and that's important because that id
that account and property id is going to
be associated with that particular
property
or website so again once you finish
setting up
the account settings then you're going
to be asked to
add some tracking code to your site and
that tracking code is going to be
related to the account
and the property so notice my tracking
id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now
this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track
and you don't have to put it on every
page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page your
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so
if you're using a you know platform like
drupal or joomla or even more
popular platform like wordpress adding
the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in
to wordpress for example and then just
simply plug-in in the id
now there's an alternative to adding the
google analytics
tracking code to your site and that's
google tag manager
so google tag manager is the way i would
recommend going so if you're not
familiar with google tag manager i would
recommend
watching the youtube video we have on
google tag manager
you can just go to youtube type in
simply learn google tag manager
and this will give you a nice overview
of
you know what google tag manager is and
how it works
but basically this is the way i would go
and i would recommend that in addition
having google analytics you set
up a google tag manager account and then
that way
you can put the tracking code in google
tag manager so if i go to google
tag manager and i just go into an
account
on tag manager i can just simply put
in the google analytics id
right into tag manager and so if i have
it in tag
manager then tag manager is going to be
the place
that holds the code and fires page view
when somebody comes to my website so
that way i don't have to add
the tracking code to my website if i do
it in
tag manager so that's the recommended
method for me
is to add the google analytics id
associated with tag manager
if you can associate it with tag manager
then that's the easier route to go
versus putting code on your website okay
so again
take a look at the video we have on
youtube for google tag manager
that's the route i would go now once you
do
get the tracking code on your website
whether that be
through google tag manager or through a
plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site
then what's going to happen is you're
going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply
want to basically understand how google
analytics works
then i would recommend getting access to
google analytics demo account
and so if you just type in and search
google analytics demo account basically
what you're going to do
you're going to choose the first listing
there and you're going to go to demo
account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login
then all you need to do is click on
access demo account
and so what google's going to do is put
this demo account
into your account and so it's going to
look something like this so if i click
on demo account here
it's going to add to my google analytics
account
so i'm going to have then access to the
demo account
from google and google analytics so i
would recommend
going this route here if you're not
familiar you're not sure what you're
getting yourself into
so think of the demo account as kind of
a test drive you're test driving google
analytics before you even add
any code to your website so again all
you need is a google account
and if you have a google account and you
add the demo
account to your google analytics account
you're going to be able to see
how analytics works okay and so that's
what i would also recommend so if you're
not ready to start adding
code to your website then what you can
do
is just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you
do actually set up a google analytics
account
you're going to have some settings that
you're going to want to pay attention to
so when you set up the account you have
the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one view
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property
is demo simply learn so that's
associated with the website we're going
to track
and then again by default under each
property
you're going to have a view and so by
default
the name of the view is going to be
called all website data
and so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to
be stored so you can see my screen here
there's a lot of different
settings you have you have settings
under
the account you have settings under the
property and you have settings
under the view so we're going to talk
more about these settings in future
webinars
for advanced google analytics users but
for now
know that there's a bunch of settings
that you have that you can play around
with
when it comes to google analytics
anything from adding users to
your google analytics account your
google analytics property review
you can actually set up goals you can
set up filters
you can set up segments you can link up
google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics
but so no those settings are there
they're located
right down here and this little sprocket
icon that's the admin icon
so if you need to get to these settings
at any time you can simply just click on
the sprocket or the admin icon and then
you'll be
prompted to choose any one of these
settings here that you want to
edit or alter so now let's take a look
at some google analytics reports
so once you've actually set up your
account you have a number of different
reports that you have available to you
in google analytics so we're going to
take a look
at you know customize reports we're
gonna look at real time
audience reports acquisition behavior
and conversion so these are all the
different reporting
buckets if you will that you have
available to you
in google analytics so if i'm in admin
and i'm looking at the google demo
account let's start out by looking at
real time so
if i click on the real time report
and i just click on overview so
basically what this is going to do
is show me at this point in time
how many users i actually have active on
the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior
of users who are currently on your
website and so
this is the overview report under real
time
and you can see here i can see that 79
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here i can see
how they actually came to the website so
this is the referring
source if they came from say search
or social i can see the source there and
i can see what pages they're active on
and then here i can see what locations
where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview
i can certainly do that if i go to
locations under real time
i could see a majority of my users are
coming from the united states
okay where are they coming from i'll
just click on
traffic sources and here i can see the
different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven
so if it's google it's either paid
search or organic search so i can see
here it's organic
then i can actually see what content
they're looking at
on my website so i can see currently
have
three active users on the home page two
active users on the
google's women's white tee page so forth
and so on
now most importantly if you have event
tracking set up
so if you're taking a look at our google
tag manager
webinar you know that you could set up
event tracking
in google analytics to measure
engagement on your website whether that
be a form submission
or somebody clicking on the play button
of a video
so if i click on events i'll be able to
see
what events are firing so here i can see
we have event tracking set up and i can
see how many different
events are firing on my website in real
time
so here i can see e-commerce somebody
clicking on the quick view
click some a couple of users clicking on
add to cart
a couple of users clicking on the
promotion click and
as these events are fired you're gonna
be able to see
them highlighted so if something gets
fired it's going to get highlighted
and i could see that these are the
current events
that i have currently firing on the
website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last
30 minutes i can just click on this link
here last 30 minutes
and it's going to give me an overview of
the events that have happened over the
past 30 minutes okay so that's event
tracking and then more importantly
we can also look at what conversions are
happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four
so in analytics you can have up to 20
goals and so here i can see
we have goal number four has already had
one active user
and so if i look at the last 30 minutes
i can see i still have only one goal
over the last 30 minutes and that was
somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally
if i'm launching a campaign or let's
just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving
then real time is a good option for you
so you can see how things are happening
in real time now let's jump down to
audience reporting so if i click
on audiences it's just right underneath
real time
i'm going to see a number of different
reports
available to me under audience and so
let's click on the audience overview
report
so audience reporting basically
allows us to get a sense of who is
coming to our website when i say
who is coming to our website it doesn't
necessarily have to be a specific person
in fact
google doesn't allow personally
identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name
a social security number credit card
information
etc however we could still paint a
nice picture on who is coming to our
website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from
what language what device do they get to
our website from
how old were they okay were they male or
female or other
what interest did they have what browser
did they use
so we can paint a nice picture based on
all this information
that google analytics is providing us
under audience
so if i go to audience overview here i
can see i have all these different
options available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example
i could see a majority of the people
coming to our website
speak english and are from the united
states okay in fact that represents
61 of the users and so google analytics
does a great job
of giving me an overall percentage so
if i have a 100 of the users i could see
61 percent of those users
represented english-speaking users from
the united states
seven percent represented
english-speaking users
from great britain and so when it comes
to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories
they're either returning or they're new
so
when you add the google analytics
tracking script to your website what's
going to happen is
if a user or when a user goes to your
website they're going to get cookied
if it's the first time they've been to
your website what google analytics is
going to do is store a cookie in the
browser
so when that same user comes back
another day
in the same browser analytics is going
to recognize that that cookie
is in the browser and so then analytics
is going to categorize that
user as a returning user okay so that's
how analytics is able to differentiate
new versus returning so if that user
doesn't have a cookie in the browser
then analytics is going to recognize
that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in
analytics you're going to be able to see
a breakdown of new
versus returning so here i can see over
three quarters
of my traffic over the past week here i
can see april 6 through april 12th
three over three quarters are new users
to the website here i could see about 23
24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming
am i driving new traffic am i driving
traffic that's been to my website before
what language are they speaking okay i
can also paint a bigger picture
how old are they are they what gender
are they do they come from mobile so
let's take a look at
some of these different reports under
audience so
if i skip down now to demographics i can
click on
overview and when that report loads i
can see now
under demographics overview i can see
the breakout of
age ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic
coming to my site again over the past
week now if i want to change this date
range i could simply do that
i can change the date range just by
clicking on the date range and then
maybe going
say the last 30 days and i can even
compare it to the previous
period or the previous year i'm going to
choose the last 30 days i'm going to
click
apply now i'm looking at data over the
last 30 days
and again you can change the date range
to any range you want
you can only go back as far as when you
actually created the google analytics
account you can't go
prior to that so here i'm looking at the
last 30 days and i can see
almost 47 of my users were in
their age range of 25 to 34. now when it
comes to gender i can see 66
represent males so i can get a breakout
of gender and age as well as interest
and click on interest and look at the
overview there
and see what the interest is of the
users who are coming to my site
based on in-market segments or affinity
i can also choose
language and location so if i want to
know exactly
where my users are located when they're
coming to my website i can click on
location
and here i can get a breakout 43
of the users of the last 30 days were
from the united states
more importantly i can align my audience
with goals and we'll talk about goals
here in a minute but
here i can see if i have an e-commerce
website
i can see of those 43 0.29
of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions
so i can get a good sense of not only
how many users are coming
from a specific country but are those
users converting
if i click on mobile and mobile to me is
one of those reports
i tend to spend a bit of time on because
i want to know
what devices users are coming to my
website and so
for my website here or this is the
google demo website
i can see mobile represents
approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic
so for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile
is definitely a majority of what people
use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
via mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating
or searching it all starts with mobile
so you want to keep an eye on mobile
and more importantly you want to keep an
eye on behavior
so google analytics is telling me that
yes i have approximately 27
of my traffic of the last 30 days came
from mobile
how are they interacting with my website
so
if i look across this report i'm going
to be able to see
different metrics so if i'm measuring
specific
metrics against my dimension
in this case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile
i can see that the bounce rate is
approximately 48
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case from mobile
landed on a page they left the
site without going any further so they
consider it a bounce
if they don't go to another page if they
leave the site
from the page they landed on and they
don't go any further that's considered a
bounce
so bounce rate is the percentage of
people
who come to the site and leave the site
without going any further
so in this case we have 48 bounce rate
that's almost
half of our users who come from mobile
leave the website
from the page they landed on so is that
good
is that bad well it's open to
interpretation is definitely subjective
but you want to keep the bounce rate as
low as possible you want to keep people
on your site especially if you have an
e-commerce website you want people
who come to your website to purchase and
so here we can see
48 mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see
how many pages on average do mobile
users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5 now if i look a
little bit further in
engagement i want to be able to measure
how long
somebody from mobile stays on the
website if they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9
almost four pages per session then that
means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough
i can see that mobile over the last 30
days
had more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34
transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough
the commerce conversion rate is at 0.29
percent
that's higher than desktop at 0.07
it's lower than tablet but it's higher
than desktop
and mobile has the most transactions and
since they have the most transactions
they have the most revenue at 2 380. so
yes the engagement isn't exactly as
great as it is as desktop but we can see
that people are still
purchasing with their mobile devices so
it's something to keep an eye on and
mobile
is something i definitely look at in
fact since it's such an important report
one thing you can do in analytics is if
you actually
like a report and you think you're going
to look at that report multiple times
then you can simply just go ahead and
click save at the top here
so if i click save i'm going to enter a
name for this report i'm just going to
call it mobile
report and click ok and then what's
going to happen is
it's going to be located under save
reports and save reports
is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if i close that up you can see
audience real-time customization
if i click on customization if i click
on save reports
i should be able to see my save report
here and i do
so here i can see mobile report if i
click on it
i can simply go to the report i was
looking at before i saved it
so save reports to me is a good feature
in analytics because it
allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more
report under audience and let's go to
benchmarking
so remember when we were setting up our
analytics account
we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and i recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt into
benchmarking
then you're going to be able to see how
your site
compares to others in the same industry
so if i click on benchmarking and then
click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare
my website with others in the same
industry so
if i go back to say jobs in education
and i choose education all education
as my industry vertical i should be able
to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry
and how i compare with those websites so
i'm choosing all countries i can narrow
that down if i wanted to
i can just search for the united states
i can choose a specific state
and then i can choose a particular site
size
so here i'm choosing sites by daily
session so these are sites that have
an average of 5 000 to almost 10
000 sessions a day and so in this
vertical education
in the united states sites that have 5
000
to 999 sessions per day
that means that there are approximately
310
web properties contributing to this
report okay based on this criteria i
chose now if my site is similar
meaning if i'm in the united states if
i'm in education
and i'm receiving 5 000 to 999 sessions
per day
then i'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now google's
sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same
with your website to those particular
websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular industries and verticals
and so now
i'm looking at a channel report so if i
want to see how i compare to
others in my industry then i can go
ahead
and see by channel for example am i
driving as much traffic as others in my
industry
and you can see i'm not in fact i'm
76 77 percent worse in terms of the
amount of traffic
being driven from organic search so
anything in red
is going to show as a negative result
a negative comparison whereas something
in green
is a positive comparison so if i look at
engagement
i can see that i might not be driving as
much traffic
but i can see that the pages per session
are better than the site average or the
industry average
i can see if i go over again looking
just at organic search i can see the
bounce rate is better than the industry
average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you
to measure how you compare to others in
your industry
and you could do so by looking at
location and devices
so if you opted into benchmarking when
you set up your account
then you'll be able to compare your
website against
others in your industry in your country
region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of
how many visitors or sessions you're
getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is
who is coming to your website
acquisition
allows us to see how the traffic was
driven to your website
so how did these users get to our
website and so
under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see
an overview of how users whether they're
returning or new
came to our website and so what
analytics does by default
is they have a number of default
channels and when we say channels we
mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how
users got to your website meaning how
did users get to our website did they
come via organic search
meaning did they type something into
google and find you
in the organic listing analytics also
groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they
type in the url directly into the
browser
or did they bookmark your website and
come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning do they come from another
website they group users by social
do they come from a social media
platform like
twitter or facebook if you're running
paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say google then do they come from paid
search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
google's network
google's display network that's a
default channel so
analytics will group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website
via these default channels and so i can
see
how many users came to the site from
each channel
now if i want to drill down on this
report i can click on
all traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels
i can look specifically at the channels
report and so now i can see
organic search again over the last 30
days
is the number one channel driving
traffic
and they represent approximately again
you can see this number here in
parentheses
next to the raw number of users i can
see that
number is about 56 so 56 percent of my
traffic
over the last 30 days came from organic
search
and so those are the number of users
again as a metric you're also going to
have sessions and you'll see
sessions a lot as a metric so users are
broken down between new
and returning so every time a new or
returning user comes to the website
basically what they're doing is
initiating
a session so you can have a user who can
come back
multiple times every time they come back
to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start
of somebody coming to your website and
the session ends when they leave the
website
and so just like we looked at with
the audience reports when it came to
mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session
average session duration we can do the
same thing
here with our channel report more
importantly
in addition to behavior we can see
conversions
and since we're running an e-commerce
platform we could see what the
conversion rate is
by channel so organic search did drive
the most
traffic and they did have the most
transactions
over the last 30 days and the conversion
rate
in this case is 0.17 okay so how google
determines the conversion rate they
basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions
so that means that over the last 30 days
organic search drove 38 123 sessions
and of those 38 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to
0.17 which also equates to 3 000 in
revenue
so i'm able to determine not only
how users are getting to my website by
looking at the channel report
i can actually see if they're engaging
and
if they are converting and notice when
you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by channel you'll
also get a summary
so here i can see a summary or a total
based on my date range so i could see
over the last 30 days i've had 54
000 users 49 000 of them
were new okay that meant that at those 4
54
000 users i had 70 000 sessions i could
see my average bounce rate was 43
the pages per session were just over
four and the average session duration
how long did somebody stay on my website
on
average about two minutes and 55 seconds
the average conversion rate was 0.14 and
had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary
and note that any report you look at in
analytics
is going to allow you to save it so if
it's a report you
think you're going to go back and look
at at a future date
then you simply just have to click on
the save button
conversely if you don't want to save it
you can simply just
export it so you can export it as a pdf
if i click on pdf
it's going to allow me to export that as
a pdf
now you have other options available to
you as well you can do
a google sheet you can export it as an
excel or you can export it as a
comma delimited file so here you can see
i can save it as a pdf if i want to
and if i click ok it's going to save to
my desktop or
location of my choosing and then i can
go back and look at it
in that format at a later time so that's
the export feature
available to you in analytics again if
you you could save it as well
or you can export it okay some other
reports under acquisition
if you're running google ads note that
you can connect google ads to analytics
and this is key
because now i can see how many
people are coming from google ads to my
website and
are they converting now this is
important because with google ads i'm
actually paying for the click
so you can see here i'm running a report
based on
campaign data so i could see what
campaigns are driving traffic
how much i'm paying per click and you
can see
on average i'm paying 34 cents per click
and then more importantly i want to be
able to see if they're converting
so you can see i've spent eight hundred
and ten
over the last 30 days and received 858
in revenue so you want to make sure that
you link up your google ads account
to your google analytics account for
this very reason you want
to be able to see how your google ads
campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so i want to see if they're engaging
and i want to see if they're converting
so there are all sorts of reports
under google ads so you can look at it
by keywords
by search queries by hour of the day
if you're running display campaigns you
can look at display
targeting so there's all sorts of
reports under google ads
you just have to link it up and you link
it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if i go to
campaigns
i can look at all campaigns so if you're
running
all sorts of different types of
campaigns whether that be
on facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising
let's just say twitter or instagram
you're gonna be able to see those
campaigns here
and that's under all campaigns and again
you'll be able to see
the campaign name and you'll be able to
see metrics associated with those
campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up
so you'll be able to look at how your
campaigns
are not one not only driving traffic but
two are they converting
let's go from acquisition reporting to
behavior
so behavior reports are going to
actually
show you how users behaved
once they got to your website once they
landed on a page
on your website how did they behave so
when we looked at audience
we got a sense of who is coming with
acquisition we get a sense of
how the traffic got to our website did
they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure
how that traffic behave once they landed
on a page on our website and so if i go
to overview
under behavior now i'm looking at this
graph here it's showing me how many
page views i've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed
it's counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site
they're initiating a session and if they
look at a page
then that page is going to have a page
view okay so
a user can look at a page multiple times
in a session
and every time they look at that page
it's going to count as a page view
so here i can see in this graph how many
page views i've had
again over the last 30 days and if i
look
further at my overview report i can see
the specific pages and how many pages
they've had
and i can also look at some other
metrics
okay the average bounce rate the average
time on
page i can look at the exit rate which
means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page
so i can dig deeper into my behavior
reporting so if i click on
site content and i click on all pages
then i'm going to look at a report by
page this is my dimension this is what
i'm measuring my page
and now i can see how many page views
each page had over the last 30 days
now note you also have something called
unique page views
so unique page use is equivalent to one
per session
in other words if a user came to my site
and looked at the home page then the
home page is going to have
one unique page view and one page view
now if the user in that same session
looks at other pages then every page
that user looks at is going to have one
unique page view
however if the user goes back to a
to the same page in the same session
then
it's still going to be one unique page
for you but in this case
the home page if they look at the home
page a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page
five times in one session then the home
page is gonna have five total page views
and one unique page view okay so that's
why unique pages
is equivalent to one per session where
page uses accumulation of how many times
the page was viewed
in the same session so in other words
you're always going to have
more page views than unique pages okay
so this gives me a sense of
how my page is performed so again i can
look at total page views
and then engagement so ideally what you
want to do with a report like this
is if a user is not engaging on the page
then that should tell you something
about the page itself if they're not
engaging if the bounce rate's high if
the time on page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something
with that page now these are all pages
but if i
jump down to landing pages my landing
page report
is showing me how many people actually
landed on that page
and so here i can see under my landing
page report
i can see the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days
that's how many people landed on the
home page so
here i can see 71 were new sessions
meaning that i had a lot of new users
who landed on the homepage in fact
25 000 or 52
of the people who landed on the homepage
were new
i could see the balance rates about 42
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session
and spent about three minutes on the
site and the one thing i like about the
landing page report
is i can also see whether that
particular page in this case the home
page
did it help contribute to a goal
or conversion and in this case i can see
of those 36 000 sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06
so the home page over the last 30 days
contributed to
0.06 of the revenue so
this gives you an idea of when somebody
lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to
move that person along meaning are they
not bouncing and is that page helping to
move people
towards converting and so that's what
the landing page in effect allows us to
measure
is the engagement and in this case we're
measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports
under behavior including site speed so
site speed to me
is an important report to look at just
like the mobile report
to me site speed's important because
what google analytics does
is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they
sampled 2 835 page views
and of that sample they came back and
said
the average page load time is about four
seconds now ideally you want to keep it
as quick as possible
i would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using
the country that you're actually
browsing that page from might not have
the best infrastructure you
may not even be on the best internet
network
meaning you're on a cell network or the
wi-fi is not that great
or you can be on a page that just has a
lot of images or
a lot of code that may slow it down so
there are other factors involved
and so what google analytics does is
show you what those factors are
so here i can see by browser what the
average load time is
if i want to look at country i could see
what country is contributing to the
low time now the great thing about the
site speed report
is if i go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do
is it's going to show me the page load
time by page
and then it's actually going to provide
a link where i can actually
click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example
i can look at this particular page here
this google redesign
shop by brand slash youtube page line
number five
if i look at line number five i can see
the average load time of this page is
eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link
next to it so google's recommending
seven total suggestions
so if i click on seven total what it's
actually gonna do
it's gonna open up a new window and it's
going to open up
another google report called page speed
insights
and page speed insights is going to give
me some information
about what i can do to create correct
the page load of that particular page so
look at this site speed report it's
important because there is a correlation
between
site speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on search
so page load times very important it's
so important
that i'm even going to save it so i'm
going to click save and click on speed
site speed suggestions as my name and
click ok
and now that report is going to be saved
under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior
to conversions now conversion reporting
is arguably the most
important section in google analytics
because what the conversions reporting
allows us to do
is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website
and so in google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals
now you have the opportunity to set up
20 goals
in your google analytics view and so to
set up a goal
okay so you're going to click on admin
and under the view you're gonna see
goals
and so if you don't even have goals the
first step
is to create goals and so you have
four different goal types and analytics
so you have pages per session so
how many pages per session is so if your
goal is set to say three
or two if somebody actually looked at
two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal
okay so if i look here i could see i
have pages per session
set at 10. so that means that
if a user came to the site looked at
more than 10 pages per session
then it's going to count as a goal
another goal type
is destination so destination means that
if somebody actually went to a specific
page then it's going to count as a goal
and in this case i can see here
that the goal is set to this particular
page here
and so when somebody actually lands on
that page it's going to count
as a goal now there are two other goal
types we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session
in our previous example if somebody
looked at 10 pages per session it's
going to count as a goal with duration
it's based on time
so in this particular case if you set up
a duration goal
and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website
and they spend at least one minute and
30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth
type of goal in google analytics is an
event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event
into a goal so if somebody clicks on
say the submit button of a form you can
turn that
event into a goal so here you could see
the category equals contact form so you
can always
verify if a goal works just by clicking
on verify this goal
and in this case this event is turned
into a goal so anytime somebody
fires this event it's gonna count as a
goal so you have four different goal
types in google analytics you have pages
per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure
goals under conversions so now if i look
at goals overview
i can be able to see how many total goal
completions i've had
so if i want to look at it by goal i can
just choose the goal
option here so if i want to look at for
example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session
i can see that i had a conversion rate
of 10
meaning that i had 7 000
of all the users who came to the website
7 000
gold completions meaning 7106
users looked at 10 pages or more on my
website
and so that's how you want to be able to
measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever pages they
look at you want to be able to look at
the conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting
based on the goals you've set up whether
that's pages per session
duration destination or event goal
conversion tracking reports can help you
measure who is actually converting and
the great thing about google analytics
here is that
i can actually see by segment so the
default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific
user set so the default segment is
always all users
however i can choose a different segment
so if i want to choose instead of
all users if i want to choose mobile
traffic i can
select mobile traffic hit apply so
i'm actually now looking at a subset of
data
i'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site
i can see 1400 engaged or looked at
10 pages or more okay and that's a 7
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types
okay based on those goal types you can
go to goals
overview and look at the conversion rate
of each goal but you can also change the
segment
of that particular goal to see who
exactly converted okay another report i
like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report
so if i click on multi-channel funnel
basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together
to convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at
under acquisition here i can see now how
different channels work together to
drive the conversion
so if i look at three channels direct
organic and referral
i can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions
if i look at direct and referral twelve
and a half percent if i look at
direct and organic twelve point two four
percent
so i can see how different channels work
together
and so if i look at top conversion paths
as an example
i can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example i can see
over the last
30 days that my top channel grouping
was direct times two meaning that
somebody came to the website directly
meaning they typed in the url in the
browser or they bookmarked it and came
to the site
okay they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct
and then converted so that combination
is my
top conversion combination of the last
30 days
my second best conversion grouping
is organic search and direct meaning
that
a user came to the website via organic
search first
did not convert and then came back via
direct
the second time and converted so
basically what analytics does
is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website
via referral or referring website and
converted
then the referring website's gonna get
the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like
organic search but that traffic may not
convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be
brand recognition price shopping
reading content whatever the case
analytics is able to
measure if that channel actually did
contribute
at a later point and in this case we
could see organic search drove traffic
that didn't convert
but that traffic came back a second time
via direct and did convert so that's our
second
best channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report
top conversion pass to me is a good
report to look at
so you can actually see not only our
channels work together but you can see
sources and mediums and campaigns and
how
all that all those different campaigns
from different sources work together to
convert
so that's just a good report to look at
there are
so many different reports available in
analytics there's so many that we
haven't even gotten to yet so my advice
if you look at the demo report you can
get a feel for each of these reports
under each section whether that be
audience acquisition
behavior or conversions take a look at
these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use
to improve your website performance now
if you have any comments or questions
about any of the reports we covered feel
free to
comment underneath this video we're
definitely going to have more webinars
in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today
and other types of analytics reports and
features that we didn't get to today how
to set up
goals in google analytics so for this
particular webinar we're going to jump
into google analytics directly and spend
all of our time there
because it's about learning practical
applications so
goals are important goals uh let me just
say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are aligned with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so
it's very important as a precursor that
you know how to set up goals
in google analytics because if you're
using google analytics
you want to measure everything against
the goal
so without further ado let's jump right
into google analytics
so if i go to google analytics and i log
in okay what i want to do
is go down to admin
click on admin here and admin will take
you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have a account
column you have your property column and
then you have your view column
now the view column is where you're
going to go
to set up goals okay so every view
in every property has up to 20 goals
okay so by default in analytics
you're going to have at least one view
for your property
so if i have a property i'm going to
have at least one view but if i happen
to set up multiple views like you see
here
then i know for every view i set up
i have 20 goals to work with so where
are those goals so under the view
i'm going to click on goals and now i
can see
i have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here
by clicking on the recording column i
can see i have
in this particular property this
particular view
i have five goals that are active so you
can use up to 20 but you don't have to
have 20 active
okay you can have one active two active
my recommendation at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring
so we have five active out of 20 total
so if i don't no longer want to use a
goal
i could simply just turn it off if i
want to continue using it just turn it
on
okay it's that simple you could turn on
and off goals
so here i already have five set up so
if you want to set up a new goal the one
thing you need to know
in google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal
okay you need to have edit access
at least the view level i would say at
the property level
so you want to make sure whoever is in
charge of google analytics for your
organization
or if you're in charge okay you simply
just want to go to user management
and user management you want to make
sure the email address you're using
to log into google analytics has at
least
edit permissions so you're going to need
edit permissions
to add new goals so i have edit
permissions
i'm going to go to goals and i want to
set up a new goal
before we jump in and set up a new goal
what is it that
we want to achieve that's really the
question we want to ask ourselves
what is the goal of the website well
if it's somebody downloading something
okay
are you measuring that download via an
event okay
are they filling out a form submission
before they download
so if they submit that form submission
is that the goal
do you have an e-commerce site is
somebody purchasing something
so these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal
what is it that i'm trying to measure
now when you actually
do go to set up a goal you're going to
click on the red
cta button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you
okay you can see them here okay if
you're somebody's registering online or
creating an account or
reading review downloading something
sharing something
you can choose all of these options here
what i normally do
is choose custom 99 of the time i'm just
going to choose custom
it doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just
a template is basically some free
pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go
with custom you want total control over
how to set
up your goal so we already have in mind
what type of goal we want to set up so
for example
if somebody goes to fill out a form
submission
and they go to a thank you page after
that well what's the url of that thank
you page
we want to be able to track how many
people go to that page because we know
if somebody does type in or fill in a
form submission and goes to that page we
know
that they filled out the form and so for
example if i go to continue
i'm going to name my goal first so i'm
going to say
thank you page as an example notice
analytics is assigning an id
so notice this is goal id 15. that means
that
that's the next available goal there are
20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does
is they group goals together so 1-5
6-10 11-15 16-20
into goal sets so for example
goal 16 through 20 is part of goal set
four
and why does google analytics combine
these goals into different goal sets
well because it's easier to ma measure
and look at data by goal sets so
for example if i jump into any report
here
if i go to all traffic channels and i
want to measure
how many goals by channel i can look at
it by goal set
so if i have goal set 1 selected then i
know
any goal i have active in there between
goal id 1
through goal id 5 i'm going to be able
to see those goals in goal set 1
and now i'm going to be able to measure
every goal i have active and goal set
one
against the channel so if i choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three etc notice i don't have
any goals
16 through 20 active that are in goal
set four therefore i don't have that
option
available to me so back to admin the
bottom left
navigation again goals okay we want to
measure somebody going to the thank you
page
we have edit access we're going to
choose
custom as our goal set up we're going to
type in a goal name
i'm just going to say thank you okay
this is goal 15.
now this is the important part google
analytics has
four different goal types destination
duration
pages per session or screens per session
so screens per session is related to
mobile
because google analytics measures mobile
app activity and then you have an event
so we're going to cover
all four of these but for the sake of
this simple example i'm going to choose
destination
why because if somebody goes to that
thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page
as the goal the goal url so
for example destination is my choice i'm
going to click continue
now this is where i'm going to put the
url so
if my url is just simply thank you.html
i can just go ahead and put thank
you.html
or if it's just thank you then i can
just do thank you
depends on the website depends on the
uri structure
so whatever that url is that's what
you're going to put in
and when you're done you can verify it
so what google analytics does is
actually will verify over the last seven
days
if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page
so if we click verify we can see zero
percent conversion rate
so that tells us that if this is the
correct url
then we've had zero percent people go to
that page
this is just an example however if you
didn't see
a conversion then you might want to make
sure you check
the url here that you put in and if you
do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so google
analytics actually has
options so we're saying thank you
is equal to so the destination url is
equal to thank you or thank you.html or
thank you.esp or whatever that thank you
page is
okay you do have options so if you have
a long
url you can say begins with and you
could say begins with say
thank you so this is the logic we're
gonna say hey if anybody goes to a url
that begins with
thank you then count it as a goal or you
could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a url
that equals two thank you
then count it as a goal you have one
more option here regular expression
so google analytics understands the
language of regular expressions
so regular expressions are just special
characters used to communicate
with google analytics in order to hone
in on exactly what you're trying to
track so we can always say you know
starts with or
ends with so we can you know use
characters like the dollar sign
ends with or begins with so we can
always do that
so you can use regular expressions as
well
if you're familiar with regular
expressions if you're not then you don't
have to use them
but there are special characters where
that you can insert
in that are used as regular expression
so if you're not familiar with regular
expression
don't choose that option you can choose
the other option of
equals to or begins with now note that
on all three of these options i didn't
put the domain
so if my domain is ama
dashfoundation.org
and then thank you i don't need to put
the domain because analytics is
already knows what domain we're tracking
so you don't have to put in
the domain here when you're entering in
in this case
the google url so you can omit the
domain
so when you put in that url you know
that you have
three options to work with and then
you always always want to verify that
goal url
you always want to verify it because if
you see zero percent conversion
and in this case of the last seven days
then that should tell you something
either your goal is not set up correctly
or you just don't have any conversions
either way you want to double check that
now when it comes to the destination url
goal
you do have an option here for funnel so
if i turn on
funnel then that means i have the
ability to
track how people went through my funnel
so if i have a cart and i want to be
able to check how many people go
in and out of the cart then i have the
option
of adding specific pages as part of the
car
so we could say you know step one which
is
basically cart we could say step two
is billing information that could be
slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping
and then step four could be you know
confirm
and that could be slash confirmation so
whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all i'm doing is putting in a
series of steps
with urls as each step and why do i want
to do that because i can then track
how many people go through my funnel
that i've created
okay so here i can see this is my funnel
that i've created
for this particular goal okay and the
funnel is only available for the
destination url so the funnel is
available
if you want to see traffic through the
goal okay
and how people go through the funnel and
where they drop off
now you have an option here to make the
first step require
so if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel
through the first step only now if i
turn that off
then i'm measuring the funnel through
each step meaning that i can measure
people
as they drop in and out of the funnel
where if it's required
the first step then i'm only measuring
traffic as it enters
in the top of the funnel so you have
that option available to you
the funnel and then for all goals you do
have a value so if somebody did
actually convert okay google analytics
is going to count it as a conversion
and you can assign a value so if you're
not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value
if you are an e-commerce website then
analytics
has the ability to track e-commerce
revenue
for your website so you don't need to
add a value but in this case
let's just say your non-profit
organization
and you're collecting donations and on
average over the past year every
donation
that somebody contributed was equal to
five dollars
well you can just go ahead and put five
dollars in there
as the value for that goal
so that means that if somebody did go
to in this example slash thank you and
convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign
five dollar value alongside that goal
so if you're not e-commerce if you're
say a non-profit
like this organization or your b2b and
you want to track some value
then you have that option there so with
the destination url goal you have the
option of adding a funnel
with all goal types you have the option
of adding
a value all goal types and we're going
to go through the rest of them
you have the option of verifying that
goal
so that's the structure of setting up a
goal destination url
is just one goal type we're going to
talk about
the other three goal types because in
google analytics there are four
goal types again destination is one of
them
with destination as you do have the
option with all goal types
is you have to be able to choose your
logic here so we're going to cover that
with the other three but just know when
you set up a destination url goal
you have the option of adding a funnel
now when you actually do set up a funnel
what's going to happen is analytics is
going to measure traffic
as it goes through the funnel so where
do you look for that funnel information
well you want to get out of admin you
want to go to the left side navigation
you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization
so based on the funnel you set up you're
going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice
on this particular funnel we don't have
the first step required
why because i could see traffic as it
goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so
here i can see the first step is the
store front page
so over this particular period of time i
have
84 sessions enter the storefront page
so out of those 84 i can see 21
left the storefront page 63
went on to the next step in the funnel
which is the cart page i can then see 24
people went on to the cart page directly
and
five exited the site altogether okay so
that gave me 87 total and from 87
i saw that 82 went on to the next page
with the next step
what analytics does is they give you a
percentage
so in the first step we had 63 move on
to the cart page
out of 84 that's 75 so from the cart
page to the create your account page
we had 94 move on so
we didn't have anybody enter in the
create your account page we didn't have
anybody
leave the create your account page so if
82
82 create your account and then we have
82
move on to the payment page so that's a
hundred percent
okay we have one exit so if 81
that proceeded to be on the payment page
which was purchased
so 81 of 82 is 98
and we started with 84 so
that gave us plus the 24 that we
accumulated along the way
so that gave us a 75
funnel conversion rate so 75 percent of
the people who
entered in the funnel went on to
purchase
okay so don't be confused with the
overall e-commerce conversion rate
so 75 is the final conversion rate
the overall conversion rate for this
particular goal
is 18.45 over this particular period of
time
why because that takes into account all
sessions that have won to the website
so 18 of all traffic
went on to convert but those that did go
into the funnel
75 converted so that's a look
at the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to
measure everything from step one and
beyond or
measure as traffic goes in and out of
the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off
how effective our funnel is what pages
we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel
and the funnel is available with the
destination url goal
so if i go back to admin if i go back to
goals
under the view i can actually see what
that funnel looks like
so here we chose regular expression so
this
is what the url is okay you can see our
funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular expressions
here
and then if we verify this goal we could
see
over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working
in this particular with this particular
goal because we do have a conversion
rate okay so that's
the destination url goals let's now
talk about the other three types of
goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session
so if you're not sure what type of goal
to set up
for your website at the very least you
should try and set up
either duration related goal or pages
per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session
so basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure
is for example if we set the goal to
three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if i
open up the goal
here i can see three pages per session
is what we're naming it
so basically what we're asking analytics
to do is
anything greater than two pages which
would be three and beyond
count as a goal so if anybody comes to
the site looks at more than two pages
three pages or more then it's going to
count as a goal and so here we can
verify it
so if we verify it over the last seven
days we could see
a four point one two percent conversion
rate and that
tells me that four percent of my traffic
over the last seven days
looked at at least three pages or more
so you're probably asking yourself well
what number should i
put in for the actual variable
so in this case we see two well what you
want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say
year to date you want to make sure you
have statistical significance so you
want to look at a period of time so if
you go to analytics
go to audience okay and then if you go
to overview
and if i change my date range to year to
date
i could see on average right now i have
1.21
pages per session so that's on average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page
we don't want to make our goal two pages
we want to make it three
so we want to be able to basically
measure at a higher rate okay why do we
want to measure at a higher rate because
if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session
really isn't moving the needle so what
we really want to do
is get people to stay on the site longer
look at pages
more uh during their session so look at
more pages
and so we want to be able to see what
segment of the audience is looking at
more pages what channels driving traffic
that's looking at more pages
what pages are contributing to more
pages per session
so the whole idea is you want to hone in
on what your goal is and see what's
working
and then see what's not working so you
can make adjustments
the whole idea beyond google analytics
is to
improve website performance and so if
our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case
you know we want to up the bar a little
bit so we're going to choose 3.
now you can choose 4 or 5 that's
perfectly fine
just know if your average is 1.2 i
wouldn't choose one page per session
as my goal and i probably wouldn't
choose two so i'd set the bar a little
bit higher
now the third goal type available in
google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long
somebody stays on the website and we
could set up a goal for that
so in this case i have a goal set for
one minute 30 seconds so my goal type
is duration so if i click continue then
basically
i'm asking analytics in this case
anybody who stays more than one minute
and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds
you want to look at that average so if
you go back to audience
overview here i can see a minute and
seven so
do we want a minute and 30 maybe we
could do that maybe we can go with two
minutes
so again the whole point is you want to
set the bar
a little bit higher than what the
average is and so
here i can see over the last seven days
if i verify this particular goal
i can see eight percent of my traffic
over the last seven days
stayed on the site at least one minute
and 31 seconds
okay they stayed greater than one minute
and 30. and so the whole point is you
can hone
in because this is a goal i can go in
this is goal
okay this is a goal here and so
i could see that this is goal 13.
so now i can go to acquisition as an
example
i can go to channels as an example since
this is a goal
this is goal 13 so that would be in goal
set 3
so i can actually see what channel is
basically
driving that goal okay in other words
what
channel is driving traffic that is
staying on the side at least
one minute and 30 seconds and so that's
the whole
idea behind goals so likewise for pages
per session we can go into channels
and here i can see we've have a over
this
period of time year-to-date pages per
session
we have three percent conversion rate
and here i can see for example organic
search
has a 13 conversion rate here i could
see
social media has a 10 percent so i could
see that
or people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more
pages than any other channel so
just like duration or destination or any
goal you set up
you can measure that goal against any
dimension
just because his engagement doesn't mean
you can't you
absolutely can and so the whole point of
engagement really goals
is to figure out what's driving traffic
to the site but
what traffic is engaging so you want to
be able to pinpoint that so you can
improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available
in google analytics is an event so if
you click on new goal
you close custom click continue you have
the option
to choose an event so an event
is something that you can measure on
your website
that analytics can't measure by default
so if you want to measure
pdf downloads or clicks on buttons or
clicks on play buttons on a video or
click on a submit button or click on an
external link
i mean you can measure pretty much
anything with an event
then you want to be able to turn that
event
into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure
a particular event that happens on the
website so in order to do so
we need to identify that event so if i
go to
for example this particular website here
and i want to measure how many times
somebody clicks on
the donate now button well if i met i
can measure that as an event
so when you set up an event in analytics
you have to actually assign
a category and an action for that event
so that's the first thing you need to do
when you identify an event related goal
first you need to set up the event in
order to set up the event
you need to assign a category an action
okay so once you identify what you want
to track as an event
on your website you're actually going to
go in a tag manager or have your
webmaster go into tag manager
and set up a tag and in that tag
they're going to assign that particular
category in action
and so here you can see we have this set
up
our category is named donate now and our
action is click
and that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate now button so anytime
somebody does that then the category
donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action
click so when you actually do set up an
event
you can go into analytics and you can
test that event so if i go to the
website
and i click donate now okay the reason
why i have this as an event
is because i'm taking to a third party
website
to handle the donations so here i can go
into analytics and now i can see
a category is being fired for header
donate with the action click
so that's my category and that's my
action
so that category in action is what is
firing after somebody clicks
on the donate now button so if i want to
turn this
event into a goal i can easily do that
now that i've set up the event now that
i've identified the category in action
i want to go back to admin and
set up the event with these parameters
in place
so just turns out we already have the
goal set up so let's go through how this
goal was set up so
first we chose custom we chose event
we gave it a name so as a best practice
when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
i would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event
so i'm gonna click continue and now that
i've
actually have set up the event already
in google tag manager
i've given it a category i give it an
action okay
see here you can see we have a regular
expression set up
so anything with the header donate
or donate is going to fire this goal
so over the last seven days i have a
0.81
conversion rate okay i could have easily
put in
equals two and put in whatever the
action what or the category which is
donate now
or i could have put action equals click
i could have done that as well
so let me show you another example here
so if i do this
custom continue event donate now
here's my goal id it's going to be an
event
so all i need to do is put in the
category in action
so donate now and then click so
that's all i have to do and that's my
goal so i can verify it
okay to see if anybody's fired it and
basically
that's what i need to do to turn that
event
into a goal okay so you need to set up
for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up in google tag manager which is
another platform
and once you've done that then you have
your category in action once you have
your category in action
you're again going to go into analytics
and then simply put in that category and
action
into the appropriate fields to set up
your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal
if you actually do set up an event and
you're just not
worthy of a goal meaning it's not a kpi
or doesn't align with your business
goals
well don't fret you can always just go
to behavior
okay you can always go to events you can
always go to overview
and measure your events that way so here
you can see
all of our events that are fired now we
do have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business
then we want to make sure we convert
that particular
event into a goal okay if it's not
important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily
have to turn that event into a goal if
you don't want to
know that it's sitting here under events
under behavior
so the point i'm trying to make here if
it's important to your business
and you're already tracking it as an
event via google tag manager
then feel free to turn it into a goal
all you need is that category
all you need is that action and so so
one final note on that event related
goal
just like any other goal you can add a
value okay
so if i have an event set up i can
choose
to add a value here or in google tag
manager
if i've assigned a value to that event
so if i go back to the actual event in
google tag manager you can see i have a
value set up for one dollar
then i can just go into analytics and
say you know what i already have the
value added
so go ahead and use the value added in
google tag manager okay so i'm going to
choose yes
now if i choose no i have the option to
add the value here just like i would
with any other goal
so just keep that in mind you can add a
value
to any goal type with an event related
goal
you can add the value right into
the tag in google tag manager just as
i've done here
so remember when you actually set up
your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in
and measure any dimension against
that particular goal so here i can see e
newsletter sign ups
by channel i can go into another goal
set
here i can see contact form submissions
okay i can see
what particular channels driving contact
form submissions
okay so just know that you can align a
goal
against any dimension so if you have
e-commerce
you don't have to set up for goal for
that that's separate
but if you want to take a look at your
goals and analytics
on its own you can just go to
conversions goals
overview here i can actually get
a good sense of how my goals are
performing
over a period of time so again if i
choose
for example year to date now i can see
based on the goals i've set up how many
total goal completion
value which takes into account the value
we've added into these goals
okay the total conversion rate and here
i can see it broken down
by the goal i actually have set up and i
can see it by
page or i could see it by source and
medium so i could see google organic is
driving the most gold completions
then google cpc direct and then
i could see some others in here as well
contributing to goals
now i do want to point your attention to
another report
in google analytics that does take into
account goals and that's multi-channel
funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels
if i go to assisted conversions
i can actually see what channel in this
example
is assisting with the conversions i've
set up
and so what do we mean by assisted
conversions well
that means that if a channel let's just
say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert
when it arrived at the website and left
but it came back a week later
via another channel let's just say email
and when they came back via email they
did convert during that session well
what analytics does
is they give an assist to organic search
because they help drive the traffic to
the website
so it's similar to the game of
basketball if i have the ball
and i pass it to my colleague and my
colleagues the one who scores because
they had the ball last
well they get the credit for the point
i.e the conversion
but i get an assist and so analytics
works the same way
they're always going to give credit to
the last click
or direct conversion but they will give
credits
to the channel in this case that
assisted with the conversion
so that's under assisted conversion and
that's based on the goals you have set
up
you can highlight any particular goal
here
if i want to hone in on say to donate
clicks
only then i'm going to be able to see
what contributed
to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that i think is
important
so after you set up your goals you can
actually see
what channels in this particular example
help to drive conversions
again this is year to date so i can see
all the different
combinations of channels that work
together
to contribute to a conversion so again i
can choose a specific
goal or i can choose all my goals
so those two reports are under
multi-channel funneling there's also
another report that i think is good
that's time lag
meaning how long did it actually take
somebody to
convert so here you can see most of our
conversions 265
year-to-date happened on the day
somebody arrived on the website
but i could see i did get some
conversions a day later two days later
etc
so you have time lag top conversion pass
assistant conversions they're all under
multi-channel funneling
and they're all available after you set
up at least
one goal and so if you're not sure what
goal to set up
okay don't fret you can always at least
set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you
duration pages per session you also have
destination
and event tracking and they're all
available to you
you have 20 available per view now
if you're not quite sure exactly what
type of goal to set up
there is an option available in
analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal
from the gallery so in other words we
could take a look
at what other people have set up
in terms of goals so you just have to
click on the button import from gallery
and i'll take you to the gallery and
you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
how to set up event tracking
in google analytics so welcome and let's
get started
so many of you out there have a website
similar to the one i'm looking at now
this is a non-profit that i work with
i'm a foundation
and like this website and probably like
your website you probably have some
interactivity on there
that needs to be tracked for example
buttons
uh if you have buttons like this one
that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a pdf
download or
a video that needs to be you know
tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so i
mean all sorts of inter
activity on a website have you ever
wondered how to track that
well there is a way to track that
because by default
google analytics can't track
interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking
and if you're in analytics and you're
always wandering around the data and you
happen to find yourself
under events well if you want events on
your website
and you want data to populate under
behavior
top events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking
is a two-part process and we're going to
talk about that two-part process
the first part of that is to identify
what you want to track okay so if we go
back to our example website here i'm a
foundation
again we noted there's a lot to track
here we gotta donate now bob we got a
newsletter sign up
we have some social icons okay we got a
donate now button here we got a play
button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says
you know purchase tickets for an
upcoming event i can go throughout the
website
and find different buttons and things to
to track let me just say this there's no
shortage of what you can track
on your website with event tracking
so event tracking is just basically in
layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
google analytics by default is only
going to track
pageview data meaning how somebody got
to your website
what page they looked at how long they
stayed on that page
what page they left from more or less
their timing
how long somebody stays on the website
and what pages they look at so
there's more to a website than just how
long somebody stayed on a page
and so in this example we want to be
able to track
everything here not just the donating
album but everything because
once you get the hang of event tracking
then it's very easy to set up okay
so step one identify what you want to
track okay
so there's a lot we want to track we're
just going to use one example
to start off with and that's going to be
this donate now button okay
so this donate now button we want to
track
now we have a newsletter sign up we have
facebook
and and that's fine you could track all
that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the donate now
button
let's focus on the duty now but and then
we'll come back and start tracking these
other things but this is what we want to
track to start out with okay so step one
identify what you want to track now when
it comes to tracking events on a website
you want to identify those events so we
did that by choosing this donate now
button
now once we identify what we want to
track
we need to assign two parameters
for that event so with event tracking
you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two
mandate mandatory parameters that you
have to assign
to everything you want to track in your
website and that's the category
and then the action so event label or
label
is the third parameter but again that's
optional okay
so basically when we identify
an event on our website we want to
assign it a category
and an action okay so why do we want to
assign it a category
in action because when we're in
analytics under behavior
under events top events we could see we
have different categories here
and we have different actions we have
different labels so if i click on any
one of these
dimensions i'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters i've entered in
for previous events i'm tracking okay so
the whole idea
is you want to be able to group
different events together
into a category and assign an action and
assign a label to it
that's really what you're doing you're
just grouping and identifying the events
you're trying to track
and so in this case i have this donate
now button
sitting in the header okay in fact i
have a lot of things sitting in the
header so
if i wanted to and i want to track all
these buttons i can create a category
called
header and then if i track all these
buttons all these buttons can sit in
that same
category if i wanted to or i can create
a
separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you
how you organize your categories because
basically all you're doing
is giving a name to what you're trying
to track and the name is equivalent to a
category
so in this case the donate now button's
very important i'm just going to call it
category header donate now i need to
give an action
to each category and so in this case i'm
just going to say click because that's
what the
action is doing it's somebody's taking
the action of clicking
now if it's a video and it's a play
button
i can assign an action of play it's up
to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all
and so in this case header donate and
then click
okay and so that's our category in
action and so that's clearly
step two so step one identify what you
want to track
step two assign a category
action and or label but remember label
is optional so if i go back in analytics
here i could see some categories
and if i click on action i could see
some actions that i've named
now step three so we've identified in
step one what we want to track
we've assigned a category in action so
step
three is going into google tag
manager to set up the event
okay so if you're not familiar with
google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
google
search for google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it
there's a good video overview of tag
manager here
that you can watch so tag manager
basically
is what we want to use to set up event
tracking now
tag managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here
is setting up an event for our website
and so i'm logged in to the same email
address
i'm using for analytics okay so now i'm
in tag manager
and i want to set up my event for
this donate now button so what do i need
to do well
for every event i want to set up i need
to set up a tag
okay so if i go to tags i can see i
already have some tags set up
and some of these are events and so when
you actually set up a tag
i recommend having a naming convention
so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it ga
dash event dash whatever it is we're
trying to set up and so in this case we
want to set up a new tag
for the donate now button on our website
so we're in google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event
so if i click on new okay and i click on
tag configuration
i'm going to choose google analytics and
then i'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in google analytics
and we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page view we're tracking an
event
and so now remember in step two
you identified what you want to call
that category you identify what you want
to call that action
and you have some optional parameters
like label so
first things first header donates the
name of our category
and our action is click and if you want
to add in
a label and a value so if you want to
assign a value you can
if you want to add in a label you can
okay those are optional
so you just need to focus on category
and action and then the last setting
here that's probably worth mentioning
is a non-interaction hit okay
so this is automatically set to false
and why is it set to false because it's
a non-interaction
no that's false we want this event if
somebody clicks on the header donate
to be an interaction so for example if i
land on this page here
and i click on that donate now button
that i'm tracking as an event
and i actually leave the site because i
have my settings set to
false i want that click to be an
interaction
then analytics is not going to count a
bounce
if i change it to true so from false to
true
then that means it is going to be a
non-interaction
if somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button
so i don't want it to be a bounce i want
it to be an interaction so
my advice is leave it set to false
we're going to choose google analytics
as our setting here
this is our variable for google
analytics so in other words
that variable is set to our analytics
property id and more or less that's what
you need to do
to set up the tag okay you need to
in step two identify the category in
action
and or label end or value now value can
be anything you want you're assigning a
numerical value so if you just assign
one anytime
that event fires in analytics it's gonna
have a value
of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires
it's going to count as an interaction
and therefore not
count as a bounce if somebody landed on
that page
so that's more or less all you need to
do to set
up the tag in google tag manager now if
somebody else is setting up the tag for
you
then again you want to revert to step
two you want to be able to give that
person
the appropriate category action and or
label
and or value why because you're the one
that's going to be going into google
analytics and you're the one that's
going to have to go to behavior
events top events and look for the
particular
act category in action and or label
so you need to be able to communicate
that information
to whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you
great you already know what it is
because you're entering that information
into tag manager so in this case i'm
going to go ahead
and choose a variable for
my label parameter and why do i want to
do that because
in tag manager i have something at my
disposal called variables
and variables allow you to see
specifically
things that are being tracked so in this
case i choose page path
okay so page path is a url and why did i
choose page path
as my variable for the parameter label
because if somebody does click on the
header donate button
and the header donate button on our
website is on every page so if i go to
the children's page
i'm still gonna see that header donate
button
and so for me i want to be able to see
what page somebody clicked on that hit
or donate button
and so this allows me to actually see in
google analytics
what page somebody clicked on the header
donate now button and so now if i go
back
to gtm google tag manager
i have a category i have an action and i
have a label which is a variable
okay so note that in google tag manager
you have a lot of different
variables at your disposal and variables
are there
to help you identify specifically what
is being tracked
so take a look at all the variables at
your disposal in tag manager
in this example i'm using page path so
now
once you set up your tag pretty
straightforward again
tag types google analytics track type is
event
you are assigning the category action
and or label
and or value you're changing or leaving
the default in place for non-interaction
hit and then
you're choosing the variable for google
analytics which is your property id
so once you've done that you have a tag
the second part of setting up a tag is
to assign a
trigger to that tag so tag manager
needs to be able to know when to fire
that event and so
here i'm going to look at a trigger i've
already set
up for this particular event and so if i
click on it
i'll be able to see that what it is is a
click
on some links not all links but some
links
i'm actually saying hey google tag
manager
fire this event when the click id
equals header donate button now it just
so happens that if somebody
did click on this donate now button
they're going to go
to another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager
i could have set the trigger to equal
url equal instead of click id
i could have said url equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my logic
for my trigger in this case i decided to
go with the click
id and so in this case that button has
an
id associated with it called
header donate button so if you wanted to
use click id
for your event for your button you could
simply
just go to the website you can right
click
on that button and click inspect element
and so when i actually inspect the
element
i can see now the button here you can
see it's highlighted in the upper pane
and in the lower pane i can see where
it's linking to
it's linking to networkforgood.com but
here you can see if i hone in a little
i could see id equals header dash donate
button so that's the click id notice
there's also a class i could have
set the trigger to equal this class or
again i could have set the trigger to
equal
the url or the page that this button is
pointing to
i could have chosen any one of those but
i decided to go
with the id so this is the id i chose
and that's the id i have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire
that event so if somebody clicks on a
button that equals
header dash donate dash button it's
going to
fire that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click
and then the label is going to be page
path so
now that we've set up our event we want
to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event
and the first way is through google
analytics so
if we go to google analytics and then we
go to real
time okay we can go to events
and here you can see one is already
fired so let's go ahead
and go to and test this and go to the
website
so if i go here for example and i click
on
amagar alumni okay so if i click on that
you can see i'm under
our family and if i click on that button
and go back to analytics and look at
real time
i should be able to see this event fire
so if i click on it
i'm gonna go to network for good now if
i go back
to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
i
can see that event firing category
equals header donate
the action equals click now if i click
on
the category here i can see the label
the label remember was page path and
here you can see
this event fired on the our family page
which was the page i was just
on so that's one way to test to see if
your event works and in this case
analytics recognize the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up
under behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events
okay and what am i going to look for in
this case i'm going to look for header
donate
okay if i click on header donate as my
category
i'm going to be able to see my action
and if i click on action
i'll be able to see my label in this
case home page
and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics i'll be able to
see under label
the page that i clicked on that hit or
donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test
to see if an event fires is if you
preview
so if i click on preview in tag manager
okay i'm gonna go into preview mode okay
and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager
and on the website what tags are firing
so here i could see
i'm in preview mode now so i'm gonna go
to the website
and i'm going to refresh and in my
browser
same browser i'm using for tag manager i
can see
the tags that are being fired on this
page already
okay because i'm in preview mode so here
i could see
remarketing i could see page views i
could see google optimize i could see
some tags that are already
firing on this page now if i click on
this button here
by holding down my shift command and
then click on that button
i'll be able to see that the tag fired
in preview mode there's my event
header donate and i can see it fired so
now i can see it fired
in the preview mode so in addition to
google analytics
in preview mode i could see that that
tag is fired
and i know that it's working so there
you have you have two ways to
test to see if the event fires again you
have real time and analytics
okay so in real time if you just go up
to real time
all you need to do is go down to events
go to your website
click on the button if you see it firing
in real time then you know it works
the second version or second way to test
your event
is through the preview mode okay if you
see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working
okay so let's rehash our steps first
step
is we want to be able to identify
what we want to track okay so it could
be this newsletter sign up it could be
click on a facebook
it could be anything we want to be able
to track an
image a click on a cta button
whatever we want to track identify it
second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in google analytics
remember label is optional variable or
excuse me value is optional
third step go into tag manager actually
set up your tag and your trigger so
if you set up a tag and it's an event
name it ga dash event that way you can
see in your list of tags in tag manager
what event tracking you have already set
up so when you set up your tag
you set up your trigger your trigger is
based on logic
that can be a url it can be a click id
it can be a class id whatever you want
to use
to fire that event and then once you do
that
you want to test it you could test it in
gtm or you could test it in google
analytics
if it doesn't fire you want to tweak
your trigger
if it does fire then great
and then one thing i would recommend is
if you're setting up
various events for your website as a
best practice
what i would recommend is set up a
spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire
it could be in this case and when
somebody clicks on the donate now button
in the header you want to put the tag
name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn
those events into goals and that's as
simple as going back into analytics
okay so if i go in analytics and i go to
admin
and i go to goals if you set up a new
goal okay
all you need to do is choose custom
click continue
you're going to choose event as your
goal name
and then from a naming perspective in
google analytics
for your goal i would definitely put
event first and then
click on header donate okay so if i
click now
continue what is my category it's equal
to
header donate my action is click and so
i can verify
to see if this is working and here i can
see
in analytics that the goal would have a
0.22
conversion rate so that tells me that
the goal is working
and i can turn this event into a goal
and when you turn something into a goal
in analytics
then you can measure it across all
dimensions
that's what i would recommend if the
event
is equal to a kpi or business goal
or it's of importance it's something you
really want to measure
okay if it's just a click say on a
facebook button i wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event
you've recorded it in your spreadsheet
it's firing
you want to be able to then go back into
behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events
okay so top events tell you by category
as a default what events are firing or
what category
is firing the most okay so if i choose
my date range
here i can just go to year to date so
here i can see
my header donate button fortunately for
me has the most
total events now noticed in analytics
you also see
unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that
unique events are equivalent to one per
session
where total events means that somebody
can come to your website
initiate a session and click on
that button multiple times in the same
session so if i go to
the alma foundation website okay i can
click on that donate now button three
or four or five different times in the
same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually
in that session count it once but
accumulate the number of clicks
as a total event for that session so
you're always going to have more total
events
than unique events because in some cases
users may click on the button more than
once in the same session
and so here i can see total events
unique events and if i added a value
to that event i should be able to see it
here so if i added a dollar
as an example to this particular event
because it had 164 unique events i
should be able to see 164 as my value
but since i see zero that means that i
did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me
how much average i have per event
so it's taking into account the number
of
or the value the total value divided by
the total number of unique pages or
sessions
and so because i don't have value i'm
not gonna have average value
but here you can see because value is
optional here i can at least see
how many events or how many clicks
i receive for a particular button again
it could be
a video if i clicked on this video as an
example
i can see how many people actually
started it
i could see the unique and the total
events and if i click on label
if i have a label assigned then i'll be
able to see
what page triggered that event so if we
go back
again to our header donate button back
to category
if we click on label as our primary
dimension
here we can see the home page had the
most unique events
been followed by the children's page the
contact form etc
so what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here i could see the home page
has accumulated the most
total events followed by the contact us
so that's
how you would look at the data in google
analytics
under behavior under events and then
under top events or overview is where
you can start
analyzing your event tracking so first
you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label
set up that tag and trigger once you do
that once you test that it's working
this is where you're gonna go to analyze
the data google tag manager
thanks for joining and let's get started
with this simply learn webinar
so let's start out with ygtm so let's
just say you're sam
and you have your own ecommerce website
you want to understand how people are
interacting with your website
well sam today's world of websites
contain a lot of interactivity
everything from videos
to pdf downloads to commenting
to form submissions uh to all sorts of
chat functionality interactivity going
on throughout the website so there's
just a lot
that you need to track outside of just
page views
and so really what gtm does
is they help you track all these things
i just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a pdf to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function
so that's what gtm is so why gtm because
it helps us track
all that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to
really place a piece of java code which
is just
script and this script that's added to a
web page
to collect information so that's really
what a tag is it's just some script
that gets put on a web page in order for
you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third
party tools okay so that's what gtm does
it it basically allows you to take all
these tags
that collect information and you can use
them
in gta so if you want to for example
collect how many people you know enter
a chat functionality and start chatting
well you're gonna take that script and
you're gonna put it in gtm and gtm will
then allow you to start tracking that
information
so that's really what gtm is it just
allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track
well you can put all those those toys or
tags in a toy box or container and we're
going to talk a little bit more about
that
but before we get into gtm let's just
say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your web page and you want to update
the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small
update your website is probably going to
not
hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally
and so normally what happens is the
developer is going to go to the website
and update the tag
well what if you have a few things that
you want to track
all those things i mentioned before from
downloads to clicks
to you know somebody checking out to
watching a video
well your webmaster your web developer
is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time
i need to put them into the work queue
so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue
usually it's going to take some time and
in some cases
you as a marketer need to launch a
campaign
and you want to get that tracking uh
added to the website
in time for the campaign launch so you
want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign
and you're sending people to a landing
page that has a form submission and you
want to be able to track how many people
click on the submit button of that form
submission well
if you need to turn that around your
developer's like well i need to put that
in a work queue
the timing isn't going to always work
out between you and your developer is my
point and so
that's where gtm comes in because there
is a solution
update your tags faster and that's
google tag manager so when we say gtm
that's what gtm stands for google tag
manager it's a place for you to
add tags quickly and easily
so tags remember are just snippets of
code that allow you to track things on
your website interactively
interactive activity and basically
when you have gtm you can bypass the
webmaster
and do it quickly and easily so that's
what gtm is all about so why
gtm because we just identified two
benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website and two
you can bypass
your web developer or webmaster and so
that's the benefit of gtm
so the benefit you get those tags
updated very quickly
via google tag manager okay so that's
what tag manager is
so what we're going to talk about today
is
specifically what tag manager is and
what it does
we're going to list some of the benefits
of tag manager we're going to show you
how it works
and then we're going to show you how to
get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
javascript and tags and all this
jargon is just new to you today okay
well
don't fret sit back we're going to take
it slow this is an introduction into
google tag manager again
let's start out with what is tag manager
so we've already introduced it to some
degree
because we already introduced is a tool
where you can
put all your tags into a toolbox
toy box or container so to speak right
and we already already mentioned that
hey you can bypass your webmaster so
you're probably thinking well if i'm
if you're not familiar with tag manager
how can i bypass my webmaster well
first of all it's a free tool and it's a
google tool hence the name google tag
manager
and it helps you really that's the main
point is deploy and track tags on your
website
by passing your webmaster so that's tag
manager
and so examples of tags that can be
deployed
via google tag manager are numerous
these are just
some examples like google analytics
facebook pixel tracking or
google ads there's no limit
into the number of texts you can track
in tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of
tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag
into tag manager and track that onto
your website and we know you can bypass
your web developer
or webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to
test and deploy your javascript codes
quicker so remember these javascript
codes or snippets of codes
are just there to track certain things
on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or
tracking somebody who converts or even
just goes to your website
so the biggest benefit is you can take
that snippet of code let's just say
facebook let's just say you're doing
facebook marketing
and you want to put that facebook pixel
on your website
so that you could track people who come
from facebook and convert
well you don't need to put that facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here
is all tags are managed in one place and
that's that to me is really a good
benefit because
when you start adding tags on your
website and you have some tags in tag
manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have
on your website needs to be in tag
manager think about that
all the tracking so if you're doing bing
or you're doing facebook or you're doing
twitter or you're doing linkedin and
you're doing google you're doing all
this type
of marketing on all these different
platforms you're gonna have tracking
code for all these different platforms
and instead of putting on that code on
your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website
you wanna put them all in tag manager so
they can be organized
and you know exactly what you're trying
to track and the other great benefit of
tag manager is there's a
versioning control so let's just say you
have added tags to your website
via gtm for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version
it's that simple so you have versioning
and that's that's a good thing when you
have versioning you can control
what gets published and if something
doesn't work after it gets published
then you can roll back to a previous
version so
it's a a piece of mind so to speak just
because you've added code to your site
there's no guarantee it's going to work
and so you can always control what
version
you're dealing with in tag manager and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
so the biggest benefit here to me with
tag manager
is you have event tracking and so we
talked about some of the things you
could track on your website
from videos from play buttons to
somebody clicking on the stop on the
video or pausing it
all the way to somebody again chatting
or let's just say somebody clicking on
that purchase button on your website
okay and you want to track all these
different things these different
interactivities
and buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons
and to me this is the biggest benefit of
tag manager and i'll show you some
examples as we go along
and if we didn't mention it already i'll
mention it again it is free
tag manager is free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going
you can add as many tracking codes as
you want there's no limit on the number
of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's free
and you can use it to its fullest
advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning
that it has different levels of
permissions okay so
you can have uh somebody just go in and
look at the different tags and tracking
code you have in gtm
or you can have somebody who is very
familiar with tag manager and can go in
and add the tracking code to tag manager
and then
publish that tracking code when it gets
added so those are all the benefits
let's talk about how it works now
specifically how does tag manager work
because you're like rob okay again a lot
of jargon
you know you you got tags and javascript
and
versioning and publishing and all this
other stuff well
i know i'm throwing a lot at you at once
but just bear with me here okay so let's
start talking about
how it actually works so you have a
website
okay whatever that domain is you have a
website and there's chances are on your
website
you have some form of interactivity
whether that be a video
whether that be a blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity
and let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe
google or facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also drive traffic to
the website
so income's google tag manager and so
tag manager is important because again
we know we want to track
people coming from that facebook
campaign or that google campaign and
interacting with our site
so if you are running facebook and you
are running google analytics well
guess what you want to put that tracking
code
in tag manager so google analytics being
a google product
works very nicely with tag manager
facebook has its own tracking code
but you still want to be able to track
people who come from the facebook
campaign to your website
so you're going to get that tracking
code from facebook and put it in tag
manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source
through tag manager so think about that
if i add facebook tracking code
to tag manager or let's just say a
google analytics tracking code to tag
manager
tag manager is the one that's pushing
out
and doing all the heavy lifting they're
the ones that are controlling
what code gets fired and what code
doesn't so if you're putting the code in
tag manager tag manager is controlling
the code think about it that way and
let's show you an example of what that
looks like
so here i am i'm in tag manager i just
went to tag manager.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so
here if i look at all the different
tracking code i have on my website
through tag manager
let's just take a look at google
analytics so if you're going to use tag
manager
you might as well put the google
analytics code in here so here i can see
i have google analytics as a tag
in tag manager now for facebook if i'm
running a facebook campaign
well i can take that pixel tracking and
put it in gtm as well
and here i could see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to
gtm i just basically took what facebook
gave me
and put it into google tag manager so
you can see
i can add facebook and google analytics
and again
i can't stress it enough any tracking
code
from any platform i can add to google
tag manager in order to track the
behavior from those sources
so let's take a little bit deeper dive
into
how tag manager works so i just showed
you an example of how you could take
facebook and google analytics code and
put it into tag manager
but if you're not familiar with tag
manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so
when you have a tag manager account you
have a container remember
i mentioned toy box earlier you have a
bunch of toys if they're
they're code and you're tracking
different bits of code from different
platforms like facebook think of those
as toys and you have a toy box
okay well that's what this code is and
that's what a container is
the code is the code and that's going to
go into the toy box or container
and so the way tag manager works is you
have tags
triggers and variables so if i take my
facebook tracking code
and put it into a container i need to
set up a tag and a trigger okay so let's
take a look at
what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager
i'm going to have an account and if i
have an account i'm going to have a
container
so here i'm just going to click on an
account
with a container and a container is
nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code
to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know
this is the website we're adding all
this code to
so you have tags triggers and variables
that's the structure of tag manager so
tags
are just what it says tags what are we
trying to quote unquote tag
well if it's google analytics that's
easy here i can see
i have google analytics added so if i
click on google analytics
here's my tag and if i take a little bit
of a deeper dive there
since google analytics is a google
product
it integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy
i can just choose google analytics then
i'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now
every tag needs a trigger okay so
i need to tell tag manager how or when
to fire the google analytics tracking
code so in this case
i'm going to tell tag manager to fire on
all pages so if i get somebody a visitor
to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
google analytics is going to fire so
that's really what it comes down to
is i have a tag and i need to tell tag
manager
when to trigger that tag that's really
what the structure of tag manager is
it's tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here
in a couple minutes but you have a piece
of code you're going to go ahead and put
that
into tag manager you're going to tag it
and then you're going to fire that
trigger
so let's take a look at another example
here if i go back
here you can see facebook well here's my
facebook pixel
okay that's my tag so when is it gonna
fire well it's gonna fire on a specific
domain or subdomain that's basically
what we're doing we're trying to tell
gtm when
to fire that particular tag so
those are the three main components a
tag okay
which is going to contain the javascript
code
that you get from say facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger
and then you have variables and so
variables
are basically just additional
information
that tag manager may need for your tag
and trigger to work so that's what a
variable is it's there
to get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into
built-in and user-defined variables so
common used variables include
say page path or page url or hostname or
click class again they're there and
these examples i just gave you are there
to
get your tag and trigger to work think
about it that way they're just
that's a component and if i go into tag
manager here
and here on the left side i can see
variables
so remember i have built in and user
defined
so built in means that tag manager
already built these for me
so in case i need to get my trigger
to work with my tag i can use a variable
so those are built in and then i have
user defined so these are
what i define these are what i created
and again the variables are there to get
the tag and trigger to work okay so
that's the job of the variable
the job of the tag is to host that
javascript code okay in the case of
facebook or analytics that's where we're
putting our code
so here if i click on adwords
remarketing again
it's a google product so i don't really
need to even deal with code
i'm just going to select google adwords
remarketing okay so you can see
gtm integrates nicely with some of the
other
google products but let's just say you
have
a facebook pixel tracking code you're
going to choose custom
and you're going to put the code here so
that's part of the tag and then the
trigger again is there to get the tag to
fire so you're telling gtm when to fire
the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure
that that trigger and that tag work
together
so that's how all three kind of work
together
you need the tag to put the code you
need the trigger to tell gtm when to
fire the tag in code
and the variable's there to help you
define
when that tag and trigger should work or
how it should work
so again review tags are they're just
small codes of javascript or tracking
pixels on your website and so tags are
allowed to manage events like scroll
track and remarketing
clicks downloads files play buttons you
name it
and even clicks on external links for
example let's just say you have a click
uh or a facebook uh icon on your site
and when somebody clicks on it they go
to facebook you want to maybe track that
you're going to create a tag okay the
trigger is there because
you need to tell gtm when to fire that
tag
so it's a certain condition whether it's
you know fire the tag if the url
equals facebook.com or some other
condition so the tag
cannot be created until the creation of
the corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together
you can't just create a tag and not have
a trigger otherwise your tag will never
fire and then the variable is there
again
it stores the information when defining
a trigger or transferring data to tag so
a variable has a variety of data okay so
you
pick and choose the variable you want to
use with that trigger
okay so you're making sure that by
defining a variable
you're making sure that you're telling
gtm
how that trigger should be fired so
let's take a look at another example
here of how all three play together
if i'm in this account i'm in this
container
if i look down here i could see google
optimize
that's another google product so what
i'm doing here
is i just chose google optimize as my
tag it's
already integrated so what does that
mean i don't even need to
deal with any code i'm just going to
select optimize
well we have the tag google optimize but
we need to tell
gtm how to fire that and so here we're
going to
tell gtm to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages
so if i want to look at something
specific again facebook
here's my tag here's my code what's my
trigger
well my trigger is it's going to fire on
specific pages
how do i know that well if i look at the
trigger
here i could see the trigger is a page
view
but i'm telling it to fire on this
particular host name
so the tag and trigger go hand in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so
you're going to go to tag
manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager and you're going to create your
account
and then when you create your account
what's going to happen is
you're going to set up a container
and when you set up a container you have
choices
so you could set it up for your website
for
an app on ios or maybe android
or you can even set it up for amp etc an
accelerated mobile page
so most people by default are probably
going to set up tag manager for their
website
and so when you do that when you
actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some google tag manager code in
return
and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying okay
google
i'm going to take this google tag
manager code and i'm going to put it on
my website
i'm going to put it on every page in my
website so
notice tag manager has two scripts
one goes in the head as high as possible
the other
goes into the body tag as high as
possible and so what you're doing
is you're making a deal you're putting
this tag manager code on your website
and
in return every code you deal with
whether that be facebook or analytics or
optimize or remarketing or whatever it
is
is going to go in gtm okay it's going to
go into the container you created
so you need the tag manager code on your
website
in order for tag manager to work okay so
when you add this code to your website
then you're free to start adding all
sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website
then none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work
so that's the idea behind the container
and then one thing i wanted to mention
on the account
is it's a google account so when you
create your account
then make sure it's the same account you
use with say google analytics or some
other google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same
email address when you set up your
account so that it integrates nicely
across
all the different platforms meaning you
can go from say google analytics right
to google tag manager
in one browser without having to log out
or log in okay so when you create the
account you're gonna create your
container
if you choose web then you're going to
be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website
then you are free to start using tag
manager and that means you're free to
start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing
google tag manager then what i would
recommend is visit the quick start guide
website of gtm so again if you're
curious as to where that code is located
in google tag manager well when you
create
an account and you create a container
that container is going to have a
specific
id so if i click on that specific id
here's where i can get my code okay so
again when i'm logged in
to tag manager i'm going to click on
workspace but in the
top navigation i'm going to see my
unique gtm id
if i click on that that's where my code
is going to be located
and so again your code needs to go in
the header and there's another
script that needs to go in the body and
if you're not sure how to add the code
to your website
well you can always click on the quick
start guide here okay
and that'll take you to a quick start
guide
page a reference page related to google
tag manager
so let's talk about creating a tag
so once you get tag manager installed
i'm sure you're excited to get going
and create that first tag so let's talk
about
how to create a tag in tag manager so
when you're in tag manager all you need
to do is
basically you're looking at all your
tags if you click on tag in the left
side navigation you'll see all your tags
and there's a new button there so you
just click new
and so basically what you're gonna do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what i would recommend
once you get tag manager installed on
your website
i would recommend setting the first tag
up as google analytics
so that will get you going with tracking
page views on your website when some
when somebody visits your website okay
so ideally that's what you want to do
you want to get google analytics
as your first tag and tag manager so
what i'm going to do
is because analytics is a google product
it's already
integrated nicely with tag manager so
i'm just going to click on
google analytics it's going to be a page
for you that's what i'm tracking
and now i have to set up a variable and
so
what it's going to do it's going to ask
me to
select a variable and so what you're
going to do is you're going to select
new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking id here
that's going to be your variable so
where do i get my tracking id
and analytics well if i'm in analytics
i'm going to go to admin
and then under property settings i'm
going to see my tracking id
and all you need to do then is go to tag
manager
and paste copy first you got to copy
over that tracking id
then you're going to go to tag manager
and paste it and then that's going to
create
a variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're going to see
it in the drop down here
so i've already created it and basically
that's your tag with a variable then
what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
i have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you
and that's going to be all pages so
ideally what you want to do
is you want to select all pages in order
for
analytics to fire on all pages so that's
what we're doing we're setting up a
trigger
we're basically telling tag manager hey
if i get a visitor to any page on my
website
then i want you to fire google analytics
so that's basically
in summary how to set up your first tag
and my recommendation is your first tag
should be google analytics and when you
set up analytics
you're going to have to set up a
variable for the tracking id
and so you get the tracking id again
from admin
property settings copy and paste that
tracking id
over save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be
included in with the tag then your
trigger is going to be all pages
and there you go you have your first tag
you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do
and once you've added that tag once
you've added that trigger
then the only thing you need to do now
is basically
publish the tag and so anytime you save
a tag
you're going to go ahead and submit it
so that way it gets published
so again what you're going to do is
let's take a step back here
you're going to choose new tag you're
going to choose
analytics from the drop down menu you're
going to choose page view
then basically you're going to add your
tracking id
so you can set up the variable and then
basically that's what you need to do
okay you're going to add that tracking
id and then voila
that's your tag with a variable and then
once you've done that
then you're going to click submit so
when you click submit
you're basically saying hey i want this
tag to go live now
this tag and trigger and once you've
done that then
analytics is ready to go and anytime
somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
google analytics
so the great thing here is you have
something called google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome
and so when you've actually added tag
manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm
if those tags are firing properly so
let's take a look
at how google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a
search for google tag assistant you're
gonna see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in chrome and
unfortunately it only works in chrome
browser it doesn't work in any other
browser
so go ahead and install that extension
into chrome and when you do that you're
going to see this nice
icon here in your browser and now if you
go to any website
and i click on google tag assistant and
i click on enable
okay so basically i'm loading google tag
assistant
and now once i refresh the page i can
see that
this particular site has google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed i can see
that it's also has google analytics
running
i have also google optimize running and
i have google ads remarketing tag
running in tag manager so that's what
tag assistant does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site
and if it is great what other tags are
firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager
so tag assistant is a great way to
confirm
if one tag manager is on the site and
two what other tags are firing
on the site now another way you could
confirm if
tag manager is firing on the site is you
can go into preview mode
so even before you submit and publish
your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview
in tag manager so basically that's going
to put me
in preview mode and so what does that
mean well that means that
now i'm free to go to my website and see
if those tags are firing and so let's
take a look at what that looks like so
if i go to the website and just click
refresh then what's going to happen
is tag manager is going to load in
preview mode
just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now
what can i see in preview mode i could
see that
i have gtm firing but i also have
some other text firing on this page
remarketing
i have google analytics i google
optimize
i have some other tags firing as well
and so the preview mode shows me what
tags are firing on any given page and i
can also see what tags did not
fire okay so here i have a number of
tags already in gtm
but they didn't fire on this particular
page so
let's just say i clicked on the donate
now button i'm still in preview mode
so i'm going to be able to see what tags
fired
now i could see i have a couple of tags
that have fired on this particular page
and then i can see what tags did not
fire on this page okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode
before you even submit a tag and trigger
to see if it fires and that's
the great benefit of tag manager so if
you're not sure if something's going to
fire or not
then you can always go into preview mode
um and if you are sure it's going to
fire
then you can go ahead and submit it so
you can leave preview mode and just go
ahead
and submit that particular tag and
trigger
so here i'm going to leave preview mode
and now
once i'm done and i'm sure the tag is
going to fire
and go ahead and submit all my changes
that i've worked on in terms of setting
up tags and triggers so that's really
gtm in a nutshell so i have
my tags okay my tags are just snippets
of code that i'm going to put in whether
that be facebook or
vet tracking or any other google
product like optimize or page view then
i have my triggers
my triggers are there to tell gtm when
to fire that tag
and the variables are there to help
those tags and triggers work together
so remember that particular variable we
set up for google analytics
okay so here it is right here because we
want to tell
gtm what property to specifically fire
in google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables google
tag manager has built in or variables
already created for you
or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable
you can always go into preview mode
preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires
then voila you can go ahead and
click submit and that will publish the
tag and trigger
and you're good to go that's pretty much
how tag manager works
and again i can't stress that there's an
unlimited number of tags you can add
to tag manager there's no limit so
you got everything from anything from
google to non-google
to event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track
you want to be able to put into tag
manager and again
there's versioning that's one of the
great benefits of tag manager so if i
want to go back to an
older version i can simply do that so
here you can see i'm on version 32.
that's how tag manager works
and i can't stress that you know tag
manager is there to help you track
interactivity
on the site because if you have a site
that's interactive that has a video
that has a download button let's just
say
you know you have all sorts of
newsletter sign ups facebook
youtube buttons on your website just
like this website does
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on that particular
button
well you're going to need tag manager
and when you have tag manager you're
going to be able to track
all of these button clicks and
interactivity on your website without
tag manager
it's going to be hard to do that so
that's an introduction to tag manager
and with that we have come to an end of
this google ads full course for 2021
i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team of experts
will be happy to solve all your
questions thank you for watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here